- I was like, "Well, why the
fuck do we have a blowtorch?
Why don't we have something
like a normal lighter
or something.
- Like a match, yeah.
- Yeah, and he went to go point it
to start a fire
and the whole blowtorch just went on fire.
And I was like, "Uh, you
might wanna put that out."
(bright upbeat music)
- Hello and welcome to another
episode of Trash Taste.
I am your host for today, Garnt,
and with me once again are the boys,
and we almost died!
(Joey laughing)
- Not clickbait.
- That's the title of this video.
That is the title of this video.
We almost died camping, guys.
Okay, now we have to do it like...
- Why did you say it so quickly?
Now no one's gonna watch
the rest of the episode.
(Garnt laughing)
- Now we have to do like
the YouTuber thumbnail face
of just...
- Oh my God!
- All right, this is my 'nail face.
(Joey gasps)
- Audio-only listeners are
like, "What's happening?"
- All right.
- How long did it take you guys
to perfect the YouTuber thumbnail face?
- Garnt, come on we can't tangent already.
We've only just started the topic.
(Joey laughing)
- This isn't a Quentin
Tarantino film, Garnt.
- No, no, no. Okay. That's the hook.
We'll start off with a tangent
and then we'll go back
to the topic of this video.
- We'll talk about that,
but in the meantime...
- But in the meantime,
how long did it take you guys
to perfect your YouTuber thumbnail face?
- No, no, no.
You're asking the wrong question, Garnt.
- [Garnt] Why?
- It's how long did it take
before you stopped becoming
ashamed of yourself
doing the YouTuber thumbnail face?
(Joey laughs)
- How long has it been
since your soul died?
- Okay, this is a legitimate question
because I still suck
at it, because I do...
- What do you mean? You
just open your mouth big.
- [Garnt] I do anime thumbnails, right?
- Yeah.
- And so my entire career
has been anime thumbnails,
and so the few videos that
I film in live action,
I've just been like a fucking
sheep in headlights about it.
- Your YouTube face is like...
- My YouTube face is
just me looking depressed
because I don't know how
to make any other face.
- [Joey] To be fair, you do it very well.
- I remember I got an angry email once
from someone being like,
"Why do you make your thumbnails
look like they're for 10-year-olds?"
"Why is your face open
and gasping like an idiot?
Do you have a penis in your
mouth or something like that?"
they were like.
- Because the general demographic
is a 10-year-old on YouTube.
- So I was thinking, and
then the explanation is,
unfortunately, "You
guys won't click on it!"
- Yeah, exactly.
- The sad truth is that it works
and it's something that you
have to come to terms with.
Someone asked me, "When you
take the thumbnail thing,
do you just depressingly sigh afterwards,
after you make the pose?"
And I'm like, "Yes."
- Yes, absolutely.
- You do.
- Wait, I gotta massage the face.
- There's no bigger "Black Mirror" moment
than when you finish shooting
that thumbnail face shot.
And then you're just like,
"Oh, okay, well now I
gotta go on with my life
knowing I just did that."
So it is depressing as fuck.
But yeah, to me, I just,
because with thumbnails,
I feel like you never
perfect it on the first go.
I feel like with
thumbnails you need 15 goes
before you know what your
thumbnail style is, right?
- Sounds like a rookie.
- Really?
For you, it's...
- One-take wonder, baby.
- For you, it's fucking easy.
- One take, no re-dos.
- 'Cause now you've got
cartoony thumbnails, right?
- It's 50-50.
That's when I'm too lazy
and then I get them to.
But also there's some
thumbnails where it's like,
"I can't possibly do a good
enough job capturing this."
So I'll do some nice
little cheesy clickbait
with a character and some drawings.
- Yeah, what about you, Joey?
How long do you take on your thumbnails?
Do you make a specific face for that video
or is it just a random screenshot
from the video you just filmed?
- Do you think you make
the best thumbnails
out of Trash Taste?
- No.
- Who do you think makes
the best thumbnails?
- Garnt.
- You think so?
I think me.
- Who's got the most views?
- I don't know.
- Garnt.
- I think it's...
- Different topics, though.
- I definitely make the
worst; that's for sure.
- No, do you?
- Yeah, I think so.
- I think 'cause you make them (laughs).
- I think my thumbnails fucking suck.
- I like mine a lot. I
like mine. I think I...
- Well, I like yours as well.
- I get criticized the
consistency isn't there.
I don't have a pattern,
but I also like that it's all
over the place a little bit.
I like that you get a different art style
every now and then.
- [Garnt] For me, I feel-
- I feel it's a bit
of a double-edged sword
if you develop a pattern
because then your thumbnails
start to look same.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But that's the good thing,
because actually, if you imagine,
you go, you've discovered
a YouTuber, right?
One of the biggest things
that puts me off is,
I've discovered a YouTuber,
his content's amazing.
And then I click on their channel
and it's all over the fucking place.
And I'm just like, "What
is this channel trying to,
what is this channel's content?"
It's kind of like an
Instagram page, right,
where it's not just about one photo.
It's about when people
click on your entire profile
and they see a portrait of
what your profile's about.
- Again, a perfect example
of why my thumbnails suck.
- Wait, wait.
- 'Cause they're all over the place.
- Okay first of all-
- [Garnt] No, no, no.
- Now I look like an
egoistical asshole, being like,
"I think mine are the best."
I do like mine though.
(Joey laughs)
- But that's 'cause I spend a
lot of fucking time doing it
and I have a bunch of people I consult.
We're like the council getting around it.
- Yeah.
- I'm like, "What do you think?"
Wait, why do you think the
reason your thumbnail...
Okay, I have several
questions I wanna ask you.
I didn't expect you to be
like, "My thumbnails suck."
Why would you upload them
if you think they suck?
- Because I can't make better ones.
- Why don't you hire someone?
- I mean...
- It's the same thing with editing.
- I could do it.
- I was like, "I'm not
good enough at this.
Someone else can take my
jumbled mess of words.
I can work with them.
They can get used to my style
and then we can go about it."
- I don't know.
Then I feel it just completely detaches me
from my content, in a sense.
- I think that's an excuse.
- I think the thumbnail is
the last little bit of me
that I can put into it.
And it's like-
- You are the video, though.
- Yeah, you are the video.
- That is true but-
- 'Cause your thumbnail style is you.
It's your face.
That is part of your style.
- I think it's also because
I don't even know what the fuck
I'm doing with my thumbnails.
I don't have a pattern
or anything like that.
I also switch between the cartoon,
my avatar version of me, and my face.
- But is it a 50-50 clear split?
Or is it, I feel like-
- No, it's mostly my face nowadays.
- It's mostly your face now, right?
- Is it the avatar when you, 'cause-
- Before, it used to be just my avatar.
- Yeah.
- I think I understand, because one,
it's easier to rely on an avatar.
You have a lot more room to play with,
and the expressions are
set and it's cleaner.
- Yeah.
- With your face, you
gotta worry about lighting.
You gotta worry about all that stuff.
- Yeah, exactly.
- I get it.
Is it when you cannot get
a good one with your face,
you bring in the avatar?
- No, I just give up
and just use a shit one.
- Or if you're not happy with it?
- No.
- Oh, I see, I see.
- I work with what I've got, basically.
- Yeah, you need get a
good artist or somebody.
'Cause even with my photos now,
you'll notice that there's text in it.
- Yeah.
- All the text is hand-drawn.
Everything's all hand-done
'cause I want to get it all to fit nicely.
When you fuck around with fonts,
yeah, you could probably do it.
- Yeah.
- But I wanna get everything perfect.
So I'll talk with someone about,
"Let's reframe this picture.
Let's move things around."
Gotta get just right, so it looks nice.
- Yeah, because like you say,
you think you have the best thumbnails,
and I think you definitely do,
for the content you make.
I mean, that's why you've found success.
I'm gonna suck my own dick here.
I feel like my thumbnails
are the most optimized they can be
for anime-style content.
- That's true, I guess it's a different-
- Yeah, it's a different type
of style of content, yeah.
- Yeah, like if I'm cosplaying,
at the time of recording,
I recently used a cosplay video.
That's so easy to make a good thumbnail.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Just literally get the
picture of the cosplay
and then just have
some, "Whoa, that's me."
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- That's what I did.
'Cause it works.
- Yeah.
- Whereas for me, 90% of the time,
if you see a video recommended on YouTube
and it has, say, a waifu's face
plastered right on the front
with a bunch of memes on the side
or something like that,
you're gonna know it's my videos.
And you're not even gonna need to see
that it's my channel,
because it's a certain style
that I've built up over the years.
- Can I backtrack, sucking my own dick?
We all make the best
thumbnails for what we do.
- Okay.
- We're all good gamers.
I'm sure somebody could
make better thumbnails
for doing the same thing.
But that's the thing, though.
You can never think, "I've
got it. I've got it nailed."
You gotta think, "How
do I make it better?"
How do I improve this?
I wanna make it pop more.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I hate thumbnails.
- What is the worst thumbnail
you think you've made,
that you can remember?
- Oh, so many.
- Have you ever gone back
and changed the thumbnail, at all?
- No.
- [Garnt] Never?
- I have...
- I'm too lazy for that.
Once I'm done, it's gone. That's it.
Once the video's live,
I do not wanna think about it.
- I used to think like that
until I saw that fucking
Veritasium video that...
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That said he goes back
and changes the thumbnail.
I tried it, and it actually
makes a fucking difference.
- Yeah.
- Some videos that I changed
the thumbnail and title
actually have a second wind
and they're doing way better
than even when they initially launched.
- I've been thinking about doing it
ever since that Veritasium video,
but I just haven't been fucked to do it.
- I love it-
- I was like, "Yeah,
I'll get to it today."
- Yeah. A lot of the older videos,
I genuinely don't want people to watch.
- Right, right.
- I'm like, "This, not the content I make.
I do not want you watching hours and hours
of Sebastian prank calling,
and then being like, 'When's
the next one coming out?'"
(Garnt laughing)
- You know? It's not. It's not coming out.
It's never coming out.
- Right.
- I'm not doing it anymore,
let me get out of this
nightmare situation.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- You're not gonna add anything to that?
- [Garnt] I was just like...
- You looked like you were
about to say something, Garnt.
- I was just like, "You know what?
I don't think I can relate."
(Garnt laughing)
- In my head, I was just like,
"Can I relate to this?
Can I relate to this?
No, I can't relate to this."
- No, because most YouTubers
who can relate to this...
- In my head, I was just like the avatar,
like, "That's rough, buddy."
That's all I can think.
- Most YouTubers who get to this point...
- All I was getting in my mind was like,
"I'm sorry. I'm sorry
that happened to you.
But I'm not reading that,"
or something like that.
I'm like, "I'm happy for you,"
or "I'm sorry for your loss,
but I'm not reading all that."
- Because most YouTubers
who get to this point
have never had to deal with that
because that channel died.
- Yeah.
- That's true, because I feel like
one of the biggest things you've done
is you've definitely changed
up your content a lot.
And you definitely, your style
and how you promote your videos,
and your thumbnails
have definitely changed
along the way, right?
So it's a nice evolution,
but for me, I've been around for so long
that there are still
videos that I'm proud of,
that I made years ago.
Not every video, of course.
- [Connor] Anime Minutes?
- Anime Minutes?
Oh, that's definitely
coming back, eventually.
- Can't wait for it to come back, Garnt.
- When's the next one, Garnt?
- It's like my "Hunter
x Hunter", you know?
It's just on hiatus.
- It's your back pains.
- I've got back pains.
I've got Trash Taste to
work on, guys, come on.
- If you didn't know,
the mangaka of "Hunter × Hunter"
has back pains and hasn't
wrote in like over a year,
I think, right?
Hasn't released one in over a year.
- It's like two years ago.
- Two years, Jesus.
RIP "Hunter x Hunter" fans.
- Before that, it was like six years.
- [Garnt] Yeah, I know.
Now I just feel bad whenever
a manga is on hiatus
because of fucking "Berserk",
how big of a meme that is,
and what that turned into.
- I saw an interview with Araki.
That man works every day of the week.
- Yeah, I bet.
- He's like 60.
- Yeah. Still looks 30.
- This man is never gonna stop.
- No, of course not.
- It was insane.
This man told his weekly schedule
and didn't mention a break anywhere.
He works from, I think, 10 AM to 11 PM
with one-hour break.
And I'm like, "Bruh."
- Yeah.
- "Bruh."
- That's what it takes, man,
to be the fucking top shonen person.
- But no wonder he has so
much musical reference.
He doesn't have time to do anything else
'cause he's just listening
to music and drawing,
and doing stuff all the time.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- Bro, yeah.
- Yeah, I can't imagine
what the actual life
of a mangaka is like,
because you see some
YouTubers on the grind.
But at least with YouTube,
you can have some variety in there.
You can collab and you can do...
- I work them all.
- Types of content.
- But I take breaks.
- Yeah.
- Well, part of the
charm is that your breaks
also happen to be monetizable, right?
Because that's like your
Twitch streams, right?
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Because for you,
that's your downtime, as well as work,
I guess, technically, but with mangakas,
you can't do anything but just draw
and work on your fucking series.
And I can't imagine being that one-tracked
and being that dedicated
to just a single thing in
your life for that long.
I can't dedicate a month
of my life to one project,
let alone five years or
10 years or 20 years.
- [Joey] Or your entire life, yeah.
- I saw a Reddit post, it was like,
what's the guy who
wrote "Game of Thrones"?
- George R. R.
- George R. R. Martin.
He apparently begged HBO
to make 10 seasons of "Game of Thrones"
instead of the seven...?
- [Garnt] Eight.
- Eight.
- Eight?
- We forgot 8th season.
- I opened this thread.
I half expected,
what did you think the
comments were gonna be
when you went to that thread,
what would you think people would reply?
- On what, him begging for 10 seasons?
- Yeah, he apparently asked for the...
- They would agree with him?
They would agree.
- Like, "Yeah, go, George."
- Yeah.
- Maybe.
- Yeah no, not at all.
They were like, "Well, if he wasn't
such a lazy piece of shit
and finished his books,
maybe they'd have
something to work off of."
Apparently...
- People suck.
- Well, I dunno, 'cause in some ways,
apparently, he, I can't
remember what exactly.
But apparently, he was helping write
some episodes initially.
And then later on, afterwards,
he wasn't helping write
any of the episodes.
- Isn't that the reason
why like the latest
seasons sucked so much?
Was that because he kind of like...
- Maybe? But...
- That was the theory, right?
- It's tough-
- I've never seen a single episode
of "Game of Thrones".
- We'll never know.
- And there was a lot of comments
and there's one or two
that I kind of half-agreed with,
where I was like, "Okay. If
you are not gonna do the job,
and you are the most
qualified person for the job,
and they're doing it, with or without you,
and you decide, 'No, I'm not doing it,'
and then it becomes shit,
can you then turn around and be like,
'Oh, it's shit. They should
have just given it more time.'"
Because the argument was like,
"If the job's gonna get done,
you're not gonna do it,
then it's your fault."
It's kind of his fault,
people were saying,
because he should have...
- It's not his fault, I mean...
- Not entirely his fault.
- I can understand a little bit
where they were coming from.
- I'm sure there's a certain
degree of responsibility.
But to say that it's all his fault
because he's the main guy,
is a little harsh, I think.
- A lot of people were
being very critical of him
in a sense that I
thought was a bit unfair,
but I understand.
- "Game of Thrones"
fans being critical, no.
- Well I think as "Game of Thrones" fans,
they've gone through all
the five stages of grief
with the books.
They've gotten to acceptance now.
- Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- They've accepted that
it's never gonna finish
and it's never coming out.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I'm pretty sure it's over.
- Hatahata fans are like, "First time?"
- I'm pretty sure it's never coming out.
- As an anime fan, I'm a hardened veteran.
I'm like, "Oh, this series
isn't finished? Cool.
Give me the next isekai.
Just give me the next finish isekai."
- This is the one time where
I opened a Reddit thread
and I was genuinely 100% incorrect
on what I thought the
replies were gonna be.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause Reddit is
normally a really simple,
first thought that comes
to your head circle jerk.
It's like, "Go for the low-hanging
fruit, get your karma."
- Yeah.
- Everyone upvotes.
But it wasn't.
- But I also find with Reddit,
it also depends very much
on the board you're on,
because depending on the board you're on,
you can get very very different replies
because it's all a circle jerk,
but it's a circle jerk of
people who think alike,
and not everyone on the
same board thinks alike,
because anyone who
doesn't just gets shunned.
You go on some Reddit threads
or some Reddit forums
and you see this thread
and you're like,
"I can't be the only one
who thinks this way."
And then you go on the Reddit thread
and everyone, seemingly
in the Reddit thread,
thinks the exact opposite of you.
And you're like, "Am I the crazy one?
Am I the fucking crazy one?"
Then you see the same thing
being discussed on YouTube
or Twitter or something,
and it's a completely opposite opinion.
So I think it very much does depend
on what board you're on
and what group of people
you are talking to,
because I can't imagine
everyone would think that
that is George's fault, you know?
- Well, yeah.
I was thinking about it,
and as somebody does creative stuff,
obviously not to the same
level and same expectations,
but you don't...
It sucks because there are probably
a bunch of creatives out there
who are legitimately just being lazy
and just chilling and not doing anything.
And they're like, "Whatever,
whatever," in making that,
and I guess in some ways
that raises the question of,
"Do the fans have a right to
demand the work come out?"
If he doesn't wanna make it anymore
and it's halfway through, is that...
- I mean, the issue is that
a lot of people don't really appreciate
how much time it takes to make good shit.
- [Connor] Right.
- Sorry, Joey. I'm gonna do this again.
I'm gonna bring up "Arcane".
Well, once again.
(Garnt laughing)
- I thought you were gonna
say "Fate" there for a moment.
- I'm gonna bring up
"Arcane" once again, Joey.
- Amazing, a masterpiece.
- Am I allowed to leave or?
- No, because that series
took six years to make.
From what I understand,
it took five or six years to make.
And it definitely feels
like it took five or six years to make,
because there's so much
attention to detail
and so many different aspects of the show.
So I can see that this
took six years to make.
At the same time,
would I want to wait six
years for a season two?
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- I don't think I would.
Here's the thing,
I dunno what I would rather.
Would I rather wait that
long for a better product,
or would I rather wait less time
for a decent product that
I can at least consume?
It's the fucking "Cyberpunk"...
It's fucking "Cyberpunk".
- First of all, "Arcane",
10 out of 10. Go watch it.
Weekly reminder to go and watch "Arcane".
Number two, fuck, I don't know.
That's tough because...
- Would you think "Cyberpunk"
would've done better
if they waited another two years?
- I think with a game, it's different,
because a game is normally one and done
like "Cyberpunk" would
be one and done, right?
It pretty much, it's over, right?
- Is it?
- No, because they can do updates.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, but like, as in
the core of the game,
there's not gonna be a "Cyberpunk 2".
If you've played it, there's
not gonna be a "Cyberpunk 2".
- [Garnt] Okay.
- If they would, I don't
know what they would do,
but it's gonna be like a one thing.
Whereas "Arcane" ended on a cliffhanger
of sorts, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So when you're ending on a cliffhanger,
it's a different question
as opposed to when you're
done, it's completely wrapped.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- 'Cause that's why we can see reboots
like 10, 15 years later,
'cause it's like, "Okay,
it's this thing that's done."
Then, oh, 15 years later,
"You liked that thing?"
- "Cyberpunk 2078".
- Right, because it's done.
It's done, so it's fine.
- Except it actually comes out in 2078.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, it totally would.
- The year is 2077.
"Cyberpunk" 2077 is finally finished.
- It'll come out, yeah.
It'll will come out like a fucking patch.
- The patch is 10 Petrabytes.
- Fucking hell.
If it's a seasonal thing
with multiple seasons,
I don't wanna wait six years.
If it's one thing that I
don't know anything about,
yeah, I can wait 20 years
'cause I don't give a shit about it.
I don't know what it is.
Give me the thing that's
done and complete, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But now that we know
there's probably gonna be
season two of "Arcane",
I don't wanna wait six years.
- [Garnt] I don't. I don't.
- Even if it ends up being mediocre
compared to season one?
- I am fine with it going
down from a 10 out of 10
to 8 out of 10.
If it means you can get it in two years.
- [Garnt] Same here.
- Because there's so much
potential to this story,
where I feel like it
would be so squandered
if I'm 50 and I'm still like,
"Waiting for Part Four of "Arcane"."
- [Garnt] Yeah, 'cause I'm going through
the same dilemma now with "Mushoku Tensei"
because from what I've heard
talking to people in the industry,
that took so many fucking years to make,
and it definitely shows
that it took that many years to make.
- That's 'cause of all
the business meetings.
- And that too. That too, on top of that.
- That was like 70%.
- [Nabi] The studio did say that
they estimate 2023 for
"Arcane" season two.
- 2023. That's reasonable.
- [Nabi] It took six years
for them to learn how.
- Yeah, I feel like the
reason why they say six years,
because they probably have
those pre-production meetings
that last god-knows-how-many-years.
When you actually start
getting all the pieces moving,
it's probably a little faster.
Now that you have more
money and more manpower,
they know that it's a success,
we know that it's very
successful, it'll you know,
and the merchandising
is endless, probably,
with this, and the games.
I think we won't be having
any shortage of "Arcane".
- They'll have enough resources, I'm sure.
I'm pretty sure Riot's gonna
give them enough resources.
But I think one thing
that isn't appreciated
is that you also need talent, you know?
- [Connor] Yes.
- [Joey] They do.
- There's been enough anime projects
that have money thrown at it,
and it doesn't help
because there's just not enough talent.
All the talented people
are working on different projects.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- So it's a dilemma.
I don't have the right
answer to this question.
- Please be a 10 out of 10
season two, I'm begging you.
I'm begging you. I need it.
- Do you think "Cyberpunk 2077"
should have come out when it did?
Probably not.
But how long would you have waited for it?
'Cause I remember when they announced
they were delaying it.
They delayed it a lot,
like twice.
- People were like,
"King, take your time, bro.
Take your time to do it."
- First time they delayed it,
everyone's like, "You know
what, take your time."
You made "The Witcher 3". I'll allow it.
Second time, that was when people
were starting to get aggy.
That's when patience was tested.
So if they delayed it a third time;
did they delay a third time?
I don't think so.
- I think the scope of the
game was just over-ambitious.
- [Garnt] I think it was.
- It was just too much.
- Yeah.
- Like in this current day,
you can't make what
they were trying to make
to the level that they were advertising.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Within a reasonable time.
'Cause you know the more
GUIs you sink into it,
there's only so many sales
you can get on a game
without DLC and battle
passes and all that.
And it was just gonna be a
game with maybe DLC, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Maybe they'd get some
micro-transactions in there,
but realistically, it
wasn't gonna be anything
that would crush numbers
we'd never seen before.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So like-
- [Garnt] I guess so, I know.
- It's like how do you
convince the investors
to stick around and be happy?
'Cause you gotta,
there's a lot of pressures
from outside forces.
- Oh yeah, it's a business.
We can't forget.
- And also, is it fair to ask people
to spend like 10 years of their life
on the same fucking thing?
In some ways I'm like, "I
guess they're being paid."
- Mangakas be like, "Just 10 years?"
- Yeah, right?
- Well, mangakas are built different.
The Japanese work ethic is just something
that we just don't have in the West.
Those dudes are chill.
- Those are rookie numbers.
Gotta pump them up.
- Yeah, they are.
- I mean, in the case of mangakas,
that's all they have.
- Even Araki said, who did JoJo,
he said that the reason why
he split it into parts of
generations is he said,
"I would get bored drawing
the same characters
for 35 years."
- Yeah.
- He had the foresight
to see that he would,
and I don't blame him.
Could you imagine you gotta
draw fucking Mickey Mouse,
like 150 times a day?
You'd blow your brain out.
You'd know like the exact
crotch size...
- That's what animes are, man.
- You'd know the exact
gootch size of Mickey Mouse.
- Can you imagine if fucking Jonathan
was still the main character
of "JoJo" to this day?
- You ended up not even
liking the character
you made after x amount of time.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- You'd lose your mind.
You'd go crazy.
- I can relate to,
because as a YouTuber,
I always like working on something new.
Working on a new kind of content,
as I'm sure you guys do as well, right?
So I can't imagine
also dedicating that much
time to just a single project.
I know there are people
who have done that,
especially in indie video games,
where it's just a one-man team
working on this one game
for fucking years and years.
- Google the Russian film
that's been in production
for like 50 years.
Just type that in. Type that into Google.
I watched this thing,
this video from Atrocity Guide.
It's about this video,
about this Russian animation producer
who hand-draws every single frame.
- Oh! I think I know who
you're talking about.
He's like the Walt
Disney of Russia, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- He's super acclaimed and famous.
His animations are insane.
It's amazing.
But he's been working
on this one animation
for a ridiculous amount of years.
It's never gonna be finished at the rate.
'Cause he's like nearly dying.
He's very, very old.
And he's not even halfway
and it's like 30, 40
years in or something.
Really long.
- What kind of movie is he making?
- It's a-
- It's animated.
- It's an animated story about,
I think it's called "The
Raincoat" or something.
- [Nabi] "The Overcoat".
- "The Overcoat". That's it.
Yeah, "The Overcoat". Is
that what it's called?
- [Nabi] Yeah.
- How many years it
been in production for?
- 40 years?!
- 40 years.
- It's been in production
has been for 40 years.
- Has he released previews?
- Yeah.
- Has he just said,
"Guys, I'm working on this
video. It's coming out."
- The yellow delay thing
comes out every 10 years.
It's like, "Guys, gimme another 10 years."
- Imagine if-
- People reply to it,
"I took work off to watch
this, what the fuck?"
- Imagine YouTubers being like,
"Guys, I'm working on
something big. It's big."
Ten years later, "Guys,
I'm still working on it.
It's gonna be something big."
- Update video every 10 years.
- They've released portions of the film
that you can watch, and
it is very beautiful.
- Yeah.
- But it's also really
sad 'cause it's like,
"Oh, this thing, this set of drawing
that has consumed this man's life
and that has drove this man to insanity
and ruined all of his
relationships and everything,"
'cause he's also like a dick to everyone.
Because every director
ever is a massive dick.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah, and he's really
apparently very harsh,
works insane hours,
makes his wife work like
crazy, as well and...
- How's he getting paid?
- I think donations.
- Kickstarter.
- [Garnt] Kickstarter.
- Kickstarter, yeah.
Indiegogo, GoFundMe, and all the works.
- God, he must have gone through
every donation platform known to man,
if he started 40 years ago.
- So they don't have any
technology in the studio.
They refuse to have any technology,
'cause of course they do.
They do it all by hand.
But it's like, at what point,
when you are making something for so long,
are you like, "Come on, fuck off.
You can't finish it. Stop
now, this is a joke."
- Yeah.
- "Sort it out, mate.
Sort your life out, come on."
- There's more to life
than just this one project.
- Well you know, it goes past the point
where you are just
letting this consume you
to a point where you're
not creating any more.
It's just taking a whole...
- It's just an addiction.
- Yeah, yeah.
This isn't healthy,
and you're not gonna finish it.
- At that point, no
matter what you release,
is never going to be
worth the amount of hours.
- Forty years of your life.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean there's only a few things
that are worth 40 years of your life.
- Don't get me wrong, it looks amazing.
But it's also very sad
hearing the story of this guy
and it just takes over his life.
- I mean, he must really love it.
I'm sure that's an
understatement of the year.
- I don't know.
I feel like,
I think it's an obsession.
- Is it desperation?
- I don't know.
It's probably one of those things where
it's definitely not
healthy, whatever it is.
It's not like a passion.
He has passion, but...
- I think it's only a passion.
- I think it's obsession.
Obsession is different from passion.
- What's the longest you guys
have ever worked on a single project?
I mean, 'cause you recently
just uploaded your cosplay video.
- Yeah.
- Very good, very good.
Because I remember every
few weeks or something,
you'd be like, "Yeah,
I'm going to a shoot.
It's the cosplay video."
I swear that went on for a
fucking year or something.
- Yeah, it took long time.
Yeah, it's all right, it was good.
It's good fun. It wasn't too long.
- [Garnt] Is that the
longest thing you worked on?
- Yeah, not hours put in,
but as in time and number of shoots,
yeah it was the most.
It's fine. It wasn't too hands-on.
Just kind of getting the
edit down was difficult.
- What's the most you've ever
put into one project then?
- Oh my gosh.
- I don't know.
- Okay, I'll go first then.
- [Joey] Is yours the "Fate" one?
- No, no, no.
The most I've ever put in was,
must be 10 years ago or something now,
I made this Top 20 list called
"The Top Coolest Anime
Characters of All Time"
or something along those lines.
- That sounds like a 2010 Gigguk video.
- How did this take you years?
- Okay, so get this. It was eight parts.
- (sighs) Okay.
- It was an eight-part series,
because I would spend...
- [Connor] Eight-part
featuring 10 characters.
- No, 20 characters.
- [Connor] Oh, okay.
- Yeah, yeah.
So every part would contain
two or three characters
and each part would be at
least 15 to 20 minutes long.
- [Joey] Right.
- And I was working on
this one single project
basically throughout university.
I basically wasn't uploading anything
but this one fucking series.
And I realized, about two videos in,
after I'd spent months
just working on two videos,
I'm just like, "I've
made a massive mistake."
- [Connor] Did you finish it?
- I did finish it.
- [Connor] Wow.
- It took me an entire year to finish.
And it took me an entire year to finish.
I remember when I finished it,
was basically when I
graduated from university...
- [Joey] Jesus.
- And I put the script of this Top 20 list
next to my dissertation.
The top 20 list was twice
the length of my dissertation
that I had worked my last year in uni on.
- Hell, yeah.
- So my dissertation,
which I spent an entire year working on,
was half the length of this
fucking YouTube video series
that I'd worked on in that same year.
- Oh my God.
- So that was-
- That's so good.
- Yeah. At some point,
it's not motivation
that's keeping you going,
because when you have a project that big,
you just wanna finish it
just so you can fucking finish it.
- Oh, yeah.
- All through, you just wanna stop.
- Yeah.
- You can't; you've started.
The Yaoi audiobook,
which took me a month of probably
at least five days a week,
eight to 12 hours nonstop.
Reading this fucking book
over and over again nonstop.
Read that book so many times, I hate it.
I hate it now. I can't look at it.
It drives me insane.
I like it. I like it a lot, but I hate it.
- 'Cause you get to about
50, 60% of the way in,
and you're just like...
- [Connor] I'm done.
- This is shit. I'm done.
I'm not doing this anymore.
Then you're like, "But I gotta finish it."
There's just something about
having an unfinished project that just...
- 50, 60% in, you can't stop.
You have to.
- People are gonna be like,
"Oh, where's EvAbridged 2.0?"
And I'm just like,
"I did the first film.
That, to me, is a completed project."
Part of the big reason I
didn't wanna continue that
was because I didn't wanna
put that upon myself again,
to start a project that I knew
was gonna take fucking years to finish.
That's what excites me,
but that's what also scares me the most,
when it comes to taking on a big project.
'Cause I've got a lot of different ideas
for a lot of big projects
I eventually want to do.
But just knowing what it's like,
where you are excited,
you're motivated for the first half,
and then that just peters off
and you start hating your project
and start hating yourself.
And you're just like,
"I just want to get this done."
That to me is such an awful grind.
- What about you, Joey?
What was your longest?
- I don't know, I mean...
- Is there a video that
stands out as being grueling?
Or anything you worked
on music-wise, anything?
- I mean, music-wise, I guess.
My first album took me like two years.
- Yeah 'cause how long
were you working on that album for?
- The first album, I took like two years.
- [Connor] That's on-and-off, right?
- [Joey] Yeah, that was on-and-off
'cause that was just like a side project.
- So you throw a little
bit here and there.
- Yeah, whenever I felt like doing it,
'cause it's not really,
my career isn't dependent on my album.
- When did you feel like it was ready
to be released?
Because I've had side projects like that,
where you do a certain percentage
and then you realize, "Wait a minute,
I might actually get to the end of this.
I might actually be able to finish this."
- I mean, the first album
was like eight tracks
and I think by track six, I was like,
"Okay, is this enough for an
album or should I add more?"
Not sure.
Then after that, it was kind
of a rush of inspiration
because it's you start
to see the final product.
The goal is right there.
I just need to run to it now.
- The last 5% is actually really fun
when it all starts to come together.
- Yeah.
The last 5% is like, "Hell, yeah."
But I don't know.
In terms of videos, not too sure.
I think the reason why a lot
of my videos take so long
is because either me, with
whatever I'm working with,
takes a long time just come back to.
A lot of it is just waiting.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- So I did that video with Ladybeard
where we run around the figurine factory.
When we did that video,
that video took like eight months.
- Oh god, counting time
just getting prepped,
it's a different thing.
- Tell me you're a Japanese YouTuber
without telling me you're
a Japanese YouTuber.
- That video took me eight months,
but seven of those months
was just waiting for
them to give me the okay
and give me a good date to start.
Then the actual shoot took
like a day and a half.
So I feel like, in terms of just
sheer working on a video time,
maybe a month is max.
I can't tell you which video it is,
but I have a couple of videos like that.
- I feel that with Trash
Taste specials there as well.
- Oh yeah.
- 'Cause like the lead...
- The specials, I think, yeah,
definitely the longest so far.
- The lead time for the
specials is just so fucking long
that sometimes you forget
that they're coming out.
You're like, "Was this a good
special? I can't remember."
I remember seeing the first draft
of the drifting special
and the cycling special.
I remember my first thought was,
"God, I can't believe
I wasted all this time
to record this shit."
(all laughing)
- By the time this episode comes out,
the cooking special's probably out, right?
- Yeah, it is.
- I mean, I guess we can talk about that
because that, oh my God,
that first draft took like how long?
- That's just because I think
it was one of those situations
where Trash Taste takes priority.
And because we're not,
'cause we know people are willing to wait.
It does take a while,
'cause it's not prioritized at all.
We don't say.
- And I guess we do
want it to be the best.
- Yeah, we don't mind making wait
'cause so much work goes into the shoot.
- It's the one thing I
don't want to compromise on
in terms of quality.
Can we talk about the Kendo special?
- [Joey] I guess.
- [Connor] Sure.
- Okay, so we released a picture
of us filming a Kendo special.
- [Connor] God, how fucking bad was that?
- That was months and
months and months ago.
A lot of viewers may have
just forgotten about it.
But I know I see some Reddit
posts every now and again,
bringing that special up.
Like, "When's the Kendo special coming?"
"When is it coming?"
We actually scrapped the special
because we filmed for an entire day.
We got all the source footage
and then Mudan edited a first draft
and we thought it was shit.
- It was shit.
- And we thought,
"There's only so much we can save
through editing and voiceover,"
'cause the source footage,
unfortunately, just wasn't there.
So we had to make the decision,
"Do we try and maybe frame this,
maybe release this as a mini-special
or maybe something different?
Maybe it goes in the After Dark channel?"
But we eventually came to the decision
that we spent an entire day filming.
We hired three cameramen, four, maybe four
and Ashley as a sound guy,
we hired the Kendo people,
and we scrapped it.
We just scrapped.
- But I think in general,
there was room for salvation,
but I don't think it would've,
I think we can all agree
it wouldn't have been up to the standard
of where we see Trash Taste specials.
- At best, it could've
been 10 or 15 minutes.
- Yeah, it could have been
a decent vlog-style video
or anything like that.
But as a special, and especially
after the cycling special,
we wanted to make something
that was at that level
of quality or above.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- The Kendo special, no
matter how much we could do,
no matter how much Mudan could do,
it just would not get to that standard.
- Yeah, exactly.
I mean, that doesn't mean we're not going
to do a Kendo special.
Part of the reason we decided to scrap it
was because we saw
potential to make it right.
- We learned a lot on that shoot.
- Well, we did learn a lot.
I mean, you don't learn
without failing, right?
- Exactly.
- It fucking hurt 'cause I remember
we were discussing what
to do with this special
for so fucking long.
I was like, "Do we release it?
Do we try and do something with it?"
And it was just on the back burner
for months and months.
It was a hard decision,
but I feel like it's moments like this
where you really really learn something.
Part of the reason I
think the cooking special
is going to be good
was because we took so many of the lessons
that we learned from this failed special,
which we may reboot to a proper special
that meets our standard,
but we took so much from
this one experience,
which was a very expensive mistake,
it was an expensive experience,
but that's kind of the quality,
the bar of quality we wanna set,
at least for our specials.
A fucking podcast,
we can just argue about bone-on chicken
or fucking whatever
shitty food take we get
for the millionth time, and that's fine.
- Yeah, but the special is something
we really wanna make
sure we hit the nail on.
The cooking special will be out
by the time this episode comes out.
- [Nabi] It's the previous episode.
It's the episode before this one.
- Oh, it's the episode before this one.
- [Nabi] This is 82, if I'm not mistaken.
- Yeah.
- [Nabi] You want the cooking special,
81 special.
- We hope you just enjoyed
the cooking special.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, by the time you
guys are seeing this,
you can see the cooking
special from last week.
But we don't know, as of
us recording right now.
So yeah, hopefully, you guys enjoyed that.
- Got robbed by Meilyne's bullshit.
- No you didn't.
- I did.
- You were never close to winning, Connor.
You were never close to win.
- You were never going to win.
- No doubt Meilyne kneecapped me.
(Joey laughing)
- Meilyne was an impartial judge.
She played her role perfectly.
- She was the chaotic evil
that we needed in that video.
(Garnt laughing)
- Impartial judge, bro.
Bro.
- Dude, dude, it's because of my sweat.
It tasted better.
Obviously, that was the reason.
- Yeah, this. You were missing this.
- If you haven't watched
it, watch the Trash Taste.
- Go watch the Trash
Taste Cooking Special.
We did put a lot of work into it.
- Yeah.
But I think the aim for 2022 for us
is to maybe get a couple
more specials out.
That'd be nice.
- [Garnt] I mean that-
- Without compensating quality, right?
- We've got a few ideas,
which I think are gonna
be really really good.
They're gonna be big, as
well, so don't worry about.
- It's all bad. We could have done more.
Yeah, we could have. We could have.
- We could have,
but it would've been really difficult
in the year that we had,
especially with the restrictions.
- It was very difficult.
- Part of the reason was,
every time we'd come
up with a special idea,
we'd just go to Meilyne or GeeXPlus like,
"Oh, can we get approval for this place?"
And they'd be like, "Nope,
everything's under lockdown."
- [Connor] Yeah, pretty much.
- And that would just delay things
for another few months and
then the next few months.
And then that was just
the first three-quarters
of the year, basically.
- And then scrapping the one special
really set us back on the schedule.
It's a bit unfortunate, really.
- So we could have had
two specials this year,
but we scrapped one special.
- Ideally, want what, three a year?
Is that the soft thing
that we set? Three or two?
- I'd like at least two.
- I think three.
- I don't want to push too far.
- As someone who just cut
back to two uploads a month...
- Let's promise two-
- It was two months.
- Let's promise-
- I'm gonna say two a year.
- Let's promise two at least,
but let's try for three.
Let's try for three.
- We'll try for three, yes.
- Because some of the ideas we have
are going to take months
of fucking planning.
- Yeah, haven't already.
- Two at least.
Three maybe.
- The optimistic side
of me says three a year.
- Yeah.
- But the realistic side
of me says two a year.
- Yeah.
- We got our streams too,
we got our streams we're
focusing on as well.
We've got this.
- And all three of us
- We'll get three.
- Fully HD.
- Let's do five. No, fuck
it, let's do one a month.
(Garnt laughing)
- One a month?!
(all laughing)
- You know, I remember when...
- So we are hiring about
20 content producer roles.
- I remember when I started Anime Minutes
and I promised one a month,
and look how that turned out.
- Well, that's just clown.
That's clown buffoonery
right there, Garnt.
Bro, how are you gonna schedule
voice acting sessions, bro?
- I thought I'd min-maxed it.
And then I realized that
I couldn't get it to the,
it actually wasn't the voice acting side.
It was just the scripting side,
where I couldn't get it to the quality
that I wanted for every series.
- I think it's also just gonna
be hard to do three a year.
Not only because of, you know,
the After Dark stuff we're doing as well.
But also just the fact that
I think on all our main
channels, we're just gonna,
2022 is just like another
step in quality up.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And just time taken, so it's like,
yeah, we need all the help we can.
(Garnt laughing)
- Basically.
- Help me, please.
- Help us.
- Help, help, help.
- Please help.
- But I would like to, just for myself,
I would like to get at least
two out a year, I think.
- I mean, we could have
easily done it last year.
And we did film two last year.
- We did do last two.
- So, if one wasn't a learning experience,
we would've had two.
So that I think that-
- If we didn't fuck up, you'd have two.
- Yeah, yeah.
Unfortunate circumstances made us fuck up.
Yeah, it's whatever.
- But speaking of something
that is not going to
be a special just yet,
we almost died!
- Can we pee?
- Wow, callback.
- I have to pee if
we're getting into this.
- Whoa, Connor needs to pee.
What is going on?
- Keep this in, Mudan.
This is rare evidence of Connor
asking for a toilet break
before me or Joey have even asked.
- [Connor] I've never asked a pee before.
Let me have this one.
- I'll take this rare
opportunity to also pee.
- Yeah, I might as well.
(all laughing)
- This episode is sponsored by ExpressVPN.
- Watching Netflix
without using ExpressVPN
is like paying for a gym membership,
but only using the treadmill.
- I can relate.
(all laughing)
- To elaborate on that
comment I just made,
ExpressVPN allows you
to change your location,
which means that you get access
to Netflix's full library of content.
- They have over a hundred
different server locations.
So you can gain access to
thousands of new shows.
This works with many other
streaming services too,
like BBC iPlayer, YouTube, and more.
- So on Netflix, I can't
watch "Saving Private Ryan".
- [Connor] What?
- One of my favorite war movies.
It's not available in Japan.
So what I do is I flick on ExpressVPN,
move it over to a new country,
and bam, it's ready
and available to watch.
- So simple.
- Plus it's compatible
with all your devices,
phones, laptops, media
consoles, smart TVs, and more.
ExpressVPN also encrypts all your data.
It has the added benefit
of encrypting your data
so you can browse the
web safely and securely.
So don't be stupid; be smart.
Stop paying full price
for streaming services
and only getting access to
a fraction of their content.
Get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com/trashtaste.
And don't forget to use our
link expressvpn.com/trashtaste
to get an extra three months
of ExpressVPN for free.
- Back to the episode.
- And we are back from our piss break.
- Why did you say that?
- Because it's kept in this time.
So they knew that we
were having a piss break.
- At least an ad in between
that or something, you know?
Just a break, otherwise,
it'd be very awkward.
- No, we're either coming back
from an ad break or piss break.
- A piss break, or
double, both, who knows?
But yeah, as Garnt said, we almost died.
- Not really.
- But not really.
It's I mean-
- It's a YouTuber "we almost died."
Under certain circumstances,
I'm sure we could have died but...
- It felt like I was
dying. That's for sure.
So you guys probably saw on
our social medias that we-
- If you don't, follow us on Twitter.
- Yes, please follow us all on Twitter
and Trash Test as well.
But we posted a couple of
photos of us going camping.
So many people thought,
"Camping Special? Your Camping Special?"
No, it's not.
- It's not a bad idea.
- It's not.
- It's not a bad idea,
but we do like to hang
out as mates as well.
- They're appalled that sometimes
we just hang out without cameras.
(Garnt laughing)
- Holy shit.
- Are we allowed to do
that? Is that legal?
- I mean, we did take pictures.
- We did.
(Joey laughing)
- Come on.
- That's not part of my contract.
- We've got cameras in there, come on.
- But we didn't film it.
- I was going vlog it
for the second channel,
but I was having too much fun,
where I was like, "Fuck it."
Maybe not.
- Vlog what? Us just getting smashed?
- Yeah, exactly.
(Garnt laughing)
- Yeah, so basically Nabi,
who works behind the camera,
as well as a bunch of his
friends and the three of us,
we went camping to Mount Fuji,
and it was fucking awesome.
- It was awesome until...
- [Joey] It was awesome
until we almost died.
- Until we had to sleep.
It is the first time I've been camping
in these kind of weather situations.
- [Joey] Same.
- So it was the first time.
So camping in England, right?
The most you gotta worry
about is some mild rain
a lot of the time.
It's like a mild annoyance.
- I've camped in the
winter before, I think.
- In the UK?
- Yeah. I'm pretty sure,
but it wasn't that cold.
- Yeah, right?
How cold does it get in
the UK in the winter?
- It depends where you are in the UK.
- 'Cause a lot of places snow, right?
In the UK?
- Yeah, snow's fine though.
Snow's all right.
- Snow's all right?
- Yeah, snow that cold.
- I mean, it wasn't even
snowing where we were
and it was fucking cold.
- [Garnt] Everything was frozen.
- Yeah, frozen is worse than cold.
- Yeah.
- When the grass is frozen, it's way cold.
'Cause when the snow's compact,
it doesn't feel as cold.
- Right.
- I don't know why.
- But we basically went to
this place called Fumotoppara,
which, if you've watched "Yuru Camp",
is the place where they're going to.
- Is that legitimately where they went?
- Is it the actual Yuru Camp place?
- I think that's actually where they went.
Yeah, it's the actual location.
- Bruh.
- Which is why there's so
many Yuru Camp references.
- They fucking lied to me.
They fucking lied to me.
They made it look comfy.
What's comfy about -5 degrees weather,
trying to sleep in a fucking tent?
There was nothing comfy about that.
- Let me give you the low down.
- Yeah, please.
- [Garnt] Please do.
- First of all, it began
in a group chat, right?
A camping trip. We're
gonna do a camping trip.
Group chat. I'm checking out immediately.
I'm that one friend that doesn't
read the group chat at all.
I don't look at it, whatever.
If you want something from me, message me.
I don't open group chats
because the moment I see 20 messages,
I'm like, "All right,
peace." I'm not reading 20.
- Gimme CliffsNotes.
- Yeah, I'm like, "Can
someone just tell me?"
- I'm sorry for your loss,
but I'm not reading that.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- I dunno about you boys. This is my POV.
It's like a few days before, and I'm like,
"Oh yeah, shit, I don't have anything."
I realized I didn't have anything.
I was like, "Oh yeah,
I have camping stuff,"
thinking back to the UK.
I'm like, "Oh shit, I
don't have camping stuff."
- Right, right.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- I thought I had a sleeping bag.
I did not have a sleeping bag.
I didn't bring a chair, forgot about that,
so I had to buy a chair last minute.
So I went on Amazon panickingly,
like two days before,
because they told me to buy stuff,
'cause I was like, "Oh
shit, I didn't buy stuff."
So I started looking,
and there was only one sleeping bag
that was available to be
delivered in time before I left.
I could have gone to a store.
I didn't wanna go to a store.
So I was like, "I'll get one off Amazon."
I'm lazy. I bought a
chair, too, and it arrived.
The chair was very heavy, very big.
And I was like, "Fuck."
- Too be fair, it was
worth it though, right?
- Yeah, the chair came in.
I think I had the best
chair in the end, actually.
It was this chair that...
- Because Joey's one had water damage
from the amount of times
he'd put it outside.
- This chair is quite
heavy, very big, I'd say.
It's not that big,
actually, yours was bigger.
But it was a chair where the
back was connected to the legs.
So when you leaned on the
back, the legs popped up,
and I don't know, man.
It was so satisfying.
- It was like a reclining
chair, but camping.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Anyway, so I got all the stuff.
I'm like, "All right, I've
been camping a ton before.
It's whatever, I don't
need to buy too much."
It's one night. One night camping is like,
"Bro, I could just do
that with my clothes.
I'll just sleep on the grass.
It's not a big deal, right? I'll be fine."
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I've done that before.
We've like slept outside
with just sleeping bags.
- We have done that.
- Oh yeah.
- Exactly. No tent.
- Yeah.
- You've done that?
- I've done it too, yeah.
- Is not a big deal. I
thought, "It'll be fine."
- If the weather's good
especially, which it was.
- Nabi was like, "Oh, did
you get thermal wear?"
I'm like, "Get thermal wear?"
(all laughing)
- I'm not getting thermal
wear, I mean, what the fuck.
I'm camping, I don't need thermal wear.
I'll wear a hoodie, bro. It's fine.
- Mind you, we went
first week in December.
So most places in Japan,
it hasn't quite gotten
to winter weather yet.
- It definitely isn't that cold in Tokyo.
- Okay, here's the thing.
He said that to me and I was like,
"I'll look how cold it's gonna be."
It predicted like one degree.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, "One degree is fine.
If I'm sleeping in my clothes,
in a sleeping bag, in a
tent, one degree is fine."
'Cause I had like a hoodie and a big coat.
I had a long sleeve T-shirt.
I'm like, "I'll be fine, I'll be fine."
I was not fine.
- Okay, we're talking Celsius by the way.
- Yeah, Celsius.
- We're talking of Celsius.
- For American, that's
four lollipops, actually,
in case you're wondering about that.
Sorry.
- It's like 36 Fahrenheit.
- It's very cold.
So that's what we thought it was gonna be.
Anyway, we had a great time, right?
We got in the car.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Played some beats, we
had a nice car journey,
two-hour car journey to Fuji.
It's pretty chill from Tokyo.
- Got the most insane views of Mount Fuji.
- Oh yeah. It was clear.
- My god, I mean you saw the
pictures, the fucking views.
The reason we went in winter was because
there's no mist, no cloud at all.
It's just a clear picture of Mount Fuji.
Every picture I took of Mount Fuji
actually looks photoshopped.
It's un-fucking-real.
- [Joey] We put that green screen to work.
(all laughing)
- [Connor] It was amazing.
There was not a cloud in sight.
- Yeah, it was insane.
- On the car there, I was
getting kind of toasty.
I was getting a little bit too hot.
I just took my hoodie off.
- The sun was out, it was beaming.
- Beaming on me. I was one-layering.
I was like, "Bro, this is gonna be easy."
Then, if all else failed,
I would have beer.
So if I got super cold,
at least I would be moderately
drunk and I could sleep.
So I thought...
- [Garnt] That was also my strategy.
- Mind over matter.
- This is a foolproof plan.
Nothing could go wrong.
- We've been camping before, me and Joey,
and we weren't going to
make the same mistake.
We bought way too many beers this time.
We bought two more crates of beers
than we actually needed in the end.
- Yeah, because I thought everyone
was gonna pull their weight.
- I mean, everyone had
around the same amount.
- Some people had one.
- Oh, really?
- Had one beer.
- What the fuck?
- From 72 beers that we bought.
That is not pulling your weight.
- I think we all had maybe
seven or eight beers at least.
- I was very drunk.
- It was like seven or eight beers.
- Imma say that some people, I heard,
weren't able to sleep during the trip
because it was so cold,
and I'm just saying I did sleep a bit.
I had some beers.
So what can you say?
What can you say, right?
What can you say? Life-hack, life-hack.
- We'll get that POV later on.
So we go to nearest
supermarket to this place.
We raid their entire beer stock,
their bread stock, their sausages.
Fuck, the sausages were so good.
- Yeah.
- There's just something about sausages
on a charcoal grill that
just hits different.
- Just meat. Just any meat.
- But sausage is the
best, I don't know why.
- Okay, I'm gonna say,
when we were buying sausages,
everyone's just like, "Oh,
just buy the original flavor."
- Buy more, buy more.
- No, you were saying just
buy the original flavor.
Just buy the original flavor.
I pick up the chili cheese
flavor and everyone looks at me-
- I don't want that shit.
- in such disgust.
Everyone looks at me with such disgust of,
"Garnt, what are you doing?
Get your trash taste out of here."
And then when we started eating it,
it was the sausage that went the quickest.
Everyone loved it.
- I like the other one the most.
- Yeah, I like the other one more.
- Fuck you, Joey. That's not
what you were saying earlier.
- No, no, because I was curious,
'cause everyone around me was like,
"Yeah, these chili cheese
ones are really good."
I'm like, "All right, bet."
I had it and I was like, "Yeah,
that's pretty all right."
- But that's not what you
said. That's not what you said.
- You haven't had a good sausage, guys.
- I was probably three or four beers in?
So I was super optimistic
and so I was like,
"Yeah this is great."
- Your Honor, he was drunk.
My client...
- Your Honor, I was not
sober when I had those.
- He was inebriated.
- You think you can use that excuse
for drunk-trying sausages?
You think that holds up in a court of law
with drunk driving?
No, it doesn't, Joey. It doesn't.
- Garnt?
- [Garnt] Can't believe I
was get betrayed by this.
- He said it. It doesn't mean
it was a good decision, Garnt.
- I didn't quite kill another person
eating those sausages.
- You killed my spirit, Joey.
- I killed my taste buds.
- When I heard that.
- [Joey] I killed my taste buds.
- You killed my spirit.
That's all that matters, man.
- [Nabi] I'll send this for production.
- So we raid the supermarket.
We take everything, we get
every condiment known to man.
I was glad, you know.
Sometimes people, when they
buy all the meat and stuff,
they forget to buy the condiments.
But arguably, we bought
too many condiments.
- This bougie motherfucker
bought Dijon mustard.
- I didn't. That wasn't me.
- Who bought the Dijon mustard?
- Someone else put it.
- [Nabi] I did.
- So Nabi, you put Dijon mustard.
- Someone put Dijon mustard
when we were on a barbecue.
I'm like, "Bro, just get
the squirty, the other one."
- It was the one in the jar,
where you have to get it with a knife,
and there was no knives.
So I was like, "What do you
expect? Just fucking..."
- We're gonna get in
the Dijon on my hot dog.
By the way, there was no hot dog buns,
'cause sometimes they
don't have hot dog buns
in the supermarkets in Japan.
So we did the Joey way of doing it,
which is folding a piece of bread-
- The Australian way.
The Australian way, it's also a sandwich.
- Getting one slice of
bread and rolling it.
- Folding it around,
that's the Australian way.
- It was kind of sad.
- That's the only way to do it.
- Okay, it's fine. It tasted fine.
But it just looked sad, it looked sad.
- It literally does the same
purpose here.
- It does the same job.
- Actually, if anything
you get to eat more-
- All bread tastes the same.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- No.
- I would argue it's better,
because you eat less bread,
therefore, you have
more space for sausage.
- I agree. I never finished
the entire sausage-
- The hot dog buns are so thick.
- The entire hot dog bun.
'Cause there's always more bread needed
than the sausage in it.
- I can't believe these takes actually.
I'm not even, you know-
- Hot dog buns are overrated.
- I'm so done. That was such a shit take.
I'm not even...
- [Garnt] What are you talking about?
- I'm not arguing this.
- [Garnt] I mean, what
are you talking about?
- I refuse to go down
to the level of clowns.
I'm not arguing this.
Let that take speak for itself.
I'm just gonna say I don't agree.
Respectfully, I disagree, Garnt.
I think the bread is the perfect amount.
Anyway. I can't believe you said that.
I'm in awe. I can't believe it.
- [Garnt] Imma say it.
- No, no, no. Okay, okay.
So we buy the all food
in the supermarket-
- It's too thick.
- Stop. It's not. It's literally not.
- On the chunk chart, it
is like the second half.
- It it's pretty thick, right?
It's like twice the thickness of-
- People who love hot dogs here
are dying right now, dying inside.
That's all I'm saying.
Okay, so we spend $400 on this food
for nine, seven, eight of us.
Yeah, 400 bucks on food. It was good.
- And booze. It was mostly the booze.
- It was like half booze, actually.
- [Nabi] Meat.
- So we bought it all,
and we finally started
setting up our camp,
and getting the fire going,
which was the most important of all.
- We had two fire pits going.
- Yeah, and then we bought
two little baby stacks of
plywood or whatever it was.
It wasn't plywood, but it may
as well have been plywood.
- Like 2x4s.
- Luckily, the store there
sold a shit ton of firewood.
So we bought a fuckton of firewood.
- Oh yeah, in Japan you
have to buy your firewood.
You can't just go into the bush.
- No, you can't.
- [Garnt] No. You gotta buy your firewood.
- Well, to be fair, in most places
in most campsites, official
ones, you can't do that.
- Oh really?
- In Europe as well.
You can't just start chopping down trees
unless the site says you can.
But most people don't know
how to chop down the tree, though,
and wouldn't know how to do it safely.
- But in Australia, we
don't like go around
fucking deforesting or anything.
But if you go out into the bush
and you see anything like-
- You can pick up
the dead leaves.
- Logs and dead branches
and stuff like that, you bring it back,
that's probably good.
- Problem is, though,
branches burn super fast.
- Right, that's why you gotta get
the thick, almost rotting wood.
- They sold these really thick pieces
of oak that were great, wonderful.
We start setting up a fire
and we started barbecuing.
It was great, man.
- Yeah, it was fantastic.
- We were having a fantastic time.
It was a comfortable temperature as well.
- It was probably like,
maybe five degrees-ish.
- Oh, I would say it was
even warmer than that.
- Really?
- Maybe six, seven degrees.
- Pretty great time, start
cracking open the beers-
- With amazing view of Fuji as well.
- Started enjoying the food.
- That was brilliant.
- Joey laughed at how I
ate a hot dog one time
or something, I don't know.
You were laughing your ass off
how I ate this hot dog one time.
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
(laughing)
We were like five or six beers in
and Connor was obviously
getting a little bit tipsy
and he took, I don't know,
it just caught my eye-
- It was a hot dog.
- I just looked over and
Connor had this hot dog bite
and it looked like the hot dog
was trying to escape out of his mouth.
- Because I shoved half
the hot dog in my mouth.
- He shoved in his mouth and just went,
all I heard was this,
you know the fucking video
of the pufferfish eating the carrot?
It does the sound.
I heard that coming out of Connor's mouth
as he was shoving this hot dog.
(all laughing)
- I was like, "Oh my God."
- Joey's like pissing himself.
'Cause I-
- I was laughing
for a good 15 minutes.
- I was like bending over
'cause I-
- 'Cause there's a lot
of sauce on there.
- 'Cause the problem was
I did the rookie error
of putting way too much condiments,
and I knew the condiments
was gonna come out, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah.
- What had happened was
I think I had taken a bite that was so big
that I either committed
to putting it all in my mouth in one go
or if I bit it and stopped,
the condiments would just go all over me.
So I bent forward and just
shoved it all in in one,
and all the condiments fell down.
- I was like, "Hey yo,
this boy's dicking down a hot dog."
- I was like raw dogging
it, I was taking it.
It was just so good, man.
I don't know what it is,
for some reason, with hot dogs,
when it comes to barbecues,
I can eat two burgers
and I'm like, "Oh, fuck."
- Yeah.
- Hot dogs, I'm like, "Another
one. Another one, please."
I'm like six in and I'm like,
"Let's go. Another hot
dog? Another hot dog?"
- To be fair, those
sausages were really good.
- I actually prefer hot dogs over burgers.
- [Connor] Yeah, me too.
- In a barbecue.
'Cause in a barbecue,
you have one burger, and that's enough.
That's enough, that's enough.
If we're gonna go with how
courses are structured,
to me, the burger is the main course.
But I can eat so much of the
hot dog around the burger.
You start off with hot dogs,
and you have the burger,
and then, for some reason,
you can eat three more hot dogs sometimes.
It's like my stomach is an infinite hole
when it comes to hot dogs.
- We also had the skewers as well,
which just got demolished in five minutes
'cause they were so good.
What is it about burgers
that is just like on a
different scale of filling
compared to everything else we bought?
- I don't know.
- [Joey] I don't get it.
- I think it's just because it takes
that much more effort to cook.
- [Joey] I guess, yeah.
- 'Cause you have to
build the burger as well,
and it's a lot bigger.
It's not just something
you can casually pick up off the grill
and just start eating.
- [Joey] That's true.
- You gotta make sure it's
a nice burger that you like.
You gotta make sure the
cheese is perfectly toasted
the way you want it to be toasted.
We tried to butter our bread
but the butter was so fucking cold
that I think it was Edo or something
who tried to put blocks of
butter on the burger bun.
So it was like squares of
butter on this burger bun
'cause it was too cold to be spread.
- And then he just like
chucked it on the fire.
- He just chucked it on the fire
and all the chunks just fell down,
and he was adamant that he could perfectly
butter this fucking burger.
- I was like what are you...
I was watching the
entire time, I was like,
"What did you want to do?"
- [Garnt] What were you
expecting to happen?
- He's just buttering the fire.
- In my mind, when
you're barbecuing stuff,
I expect the quality of this burger
to not be as on par as a restaurant.
I don't need my barbecued
burger buttered bun.
I'm like, "You can just
toast it. It's fine."
- But it wasn't even the worst idea
that happened during the-
- [Connor] This is a good idea.
I know what you're gonna say.
- You know when you're a few drinks in
and you do something that
you think is a good idea.
- Genius idea.
- So we also had eggs,
but we had nowhere to cook the eggs.
- 'Cause it's a grill.
- We didn't bring pans or anything.
- No, no pans.
We just had a grill, a mesh grill.
So Connor comes up with the idea
of trying to cook this
egg on a burger bun.
- I really wanted an egg on my burger.
- So what he does is he
places the patty on the grill.
- No, it was the bun.
- Oh, sorry. It was the bun.
He places the bun on the grill
and then he cracks an egg on top of it.
Naturally, all the white of the egg
just fucking spills over
the edge and into the fire.
- I knew that would happen.
- All that's left is a fucking yolk,
and this yolk is, it's like ice hockey.
It was just like slippering
around on this thing,
and he's just like trying to control it.
In the end, it spilled over.
- Went in the fire.
- It was a very sad moment.
- I was saying there's no way
you could cook a egg on
a burger bun on a grill.
There's so many things that can go wrong
and it did go wrong.
- Here's what my thinking was.
Obviously, I was a few beers in,
but I thought that the flames
of the fire were so big,
'cause it was enveloping the bun.
I was like, "It'll reach
the egg. It'll cook the egg.
It'll do it. It'll do it.
It's hot enough. It'll do it."
- The entire time, as well,
he was like "Galaxy brain. Galaxy brain.
Watch this. Gamer moment. Gamer moment."
It's just like, "You are
wasting a perfectly good egg."
- No. I had an eggy bun,
and it gave the good
egg flavor to my burger.
- What do you mean?
There was like 1/5 of the yolk left.
- Hey, it was good.
- [Garnt] You just made eggy bread.
- Don't hate. I liked it.
I liked it. It was good. It was good.
- It's like the world's
shittiest French toast.
- It was amazing. I had a great burger.
- [Nabi] Wrap in aluminum foil.
- You were so dedicated
to cooking this egg,
and it was like watching someone
try to solve that Zelda puzzle
in "Breath of the Wild".
We know how fucking shitty it is,
controlling that puzzle with
your Wiimote or whatever.
- You guys sit in your
comfort of knowing what works.
I am the daring type,
who tried something new.
I wanted to see if I could get an egg
to cook on a burger bun.
- I knew it wasn't gonna go well
because the whole ordeal started
with Connor going, "Watch this."
Anything that starts with
a confident "watch this"
five beers in, is not going to go well.
- "Hold my beer." Imagine
if it worked, though.
I'd have been a fucking god.
- I would've applauded you.
- I would've been a god amongst men.
- Yes.
- If I made that work, I would've.
That would've been amazing.
But like Icarus, I flew
too close to the sun.
I tried something that I shouldn't have.
What can I say?
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Then you gave up and just
like flipped the burger,
and then the rest of the
egg slid into the fire.
- I was like, "If I can't have the egg
cook perfectly on the bun,
I'll at least have this
French toast flavor
to add to my burger.
It added the flavor profile
that I was quite happy with.
- Suffice it to say that
the dinner went well.
Then, under the stars,
it was amazing starlight.
- [Garnt] View was amazing.
- Mount Fuji in the background.
We had a good time.
- There was a problem, though.
We were running out of wood,
and the store had closed.
- I was going to say,
so we ate like kings
and we drank like kings.
We learned from the last camping trip.
We overstocked on pretty
much every fucking resource
we could think of.
- Food we did perfectly.
- We had a bunch of food left.
- We still had a bunch of food left.
- I thought we ate it all.
- I ate it while you were sleeping.
- If somebody had told
me, I would've ate it all.
(Joey laughing)
- I would have been done with it.
- It's because we ran out of coal,
and we ran out of firewood.
In camping outside on a winter's night,
we ran out of the one
resource that is essential
for basically human
survival, which is heat.
- It kind of sucked, 'cause it was like,
"Oh, I'm pretty sure we
could still keep going."
But it got to about 11
PM and we could see then.
- No, no. I remember.
It got to about 9 PM.
I remember 'cause it got to about 9 PM
and we still wanted to
cook some more food,
but the wood just wasn't
bringing enough heat
to actually cook stuff,
because it was just charring
it and then going out,
'cause we needed coal for it.
So we decided to stop cooking
and just keep on drinking, as you do.
Keep going with the liquid dinner.
I remember it hit about 9 PM
and it started getting a bit nippy,
it started going from a
comfortable temperature
to, "Okay, now I gotta
put on this winter jacket
because I'm actually
starting to feel this cold."
- Yeah. I went down to around
two, three degrees Celsius.
- Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Then I remember
looking at the firewood.
We had somehow gone through
about 70% of the firewood
that we had bought previously.
I remember thinking,
"Fuck. How much longer is
this going to last us?"
I remember it was at that point
that I think we subconsciously
started to ration it,
because it got colder,
but I remember the fires
also started to get colder as well,
'cause we weren't putting in the wood
all willy nilly anymore.
- I noticed that people
were slowly approaching the
fire pit, closer and closer.
- I was further away, initially.
'Cause I was like, "I
don't need that much.
I'm fine. I'm hot."
But then got to the
point where I was like,
"Oh, I need the fire or I'm
actually gonna just die."
- Yeah. Our knees were
basically in the fire.
- Made me realize how shitty fires are.
They must have had to
literally sleep next to it,
'cause I'm like, "This shit is awful.
The range of this fire is terrible."
Air is a terrible insulator.
But I was like, "This is terrible.
I have to basically have
my hands in this thing
to be warm."
- I can't believe Nature
nerfed the AoE of fire.
- Can they fix that patch?
Can I have the range increase of fire?
It was not good.
- Yeah. I dunno what
fucking Newton was thinking.
What's up with that? What's up?
- You could try wind nerfing the AoE.
It's too powerful.
- I remember the fire was hot
enough, being close to it,
but then my ass was freezing fucking cold.
- Oh yeah.
- So every so often, I'd
just have to put my ass
on top of the fire.
Joey was just farting nonstop
throughout the entire camping trip.
Every time he put his ass across the fire,
I'm like, "Joey, please
don't fart right now."
I held my breath, 'cause
I knew if Joey farted,
I swear to God, it would've used up
the rest of the firewood.
- The fire just starts to...
- No. No. First of all, when
you stand up for a moment,
the chair that you've been
warming up for 30 minutes
instantly becomes cold again.
- It instantly freezes.
- Which sucks. Which meant
you didn't wanna move,
but you had to pee.
You had to also put stuff
on the fire or whatever.
So it was awful.
Also, one thing that
happened where I was like,
"We're gonna die,"
is that they try to
light the fire starters
with a gas fire.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Joey laughing)
- [Garnt] I remember that.
- So they tried to light,
one of the guys turned
on the gas for this,
what would you even call it?
- [Garnt] Blowtorch.
- Propane torch.
- Blowtorch.
I was like, "Why the fuck
do we have a blowtorch?
Why do we have something
like a normal lighter?"
- Like a match.
- I don't know. But we had
a blowtorch, and he lit it,
and he went to go and
point it to start a fire,
and the whole blowtorch just went on fire.
I was like, "Uh. You
might wanna put that out."
The torch was catching on fire,
the gas canister's right next to it.
I'm like "Uh-oh. Uh-oh.
Fire plus can pressure.
Uh-oh. Uh-oh."
And I was like, "I'm getting away.
What the fuck? Put it out! Put it out!"
- But the thing is, we
were six or seven people.
Everybody else is just
kind of sitting there like,
"Oh, it's on fire."
- I remember that exact moment.
- I backed off. I was running away.
People are just sitting there watching,
not helping at all,
just watching this guy holding
this gas canister on fire.
I'm like, "I'm running away."
I'm like, "What the fuck
are you guys doing? Run!"
- Yeah.
I remember my exact POV was
I see it happen.
I see him pointing it towards the fire.
He presses the button and
then the gas just leaks
throughout the entire can.
So the entire can is just covered.
Connor goes "fight or flight" mode.
He's just like when that one quiet kid
reached for his bag, you know.
He's half a mile down.
- [Connor] I'm not liking this.
- Me, being six cans of
beers in, I'm just like,
"Oh, fire."
(all laughing)
- It was only after Connor's like,
"Guys, what the fuck are you
doing? We almost just died!"
And I'm just like, "But
the fire. It's so pretty."
- [Joey] Yeah.
He was holding fire. That's so cool.
- These guys didn't even say anything.
They literally sat there like
stoners, just watching this.
- I literally saw him
holding this can of fire,
and I was like (laughs).
- The guy who was holding it,
(Joey laughs)
- I can't remember who was holding it,
but I was like, "Turn it
off! Turn the gas off!"
- Yeah. Wayne was holding it.
Our friend Wayne was holding it.
He was like, "Oh."
- He didn't what to do.
- "What should I do?"
- I'm like, "Turn it off! Turn it off!"
- There was about to be an ass...
- I ran to a distance and then
I was giving instructions.
I was like, "Now turn it off!"
- I remember you running to a distance,
and you're like, "Guys, what
the fuck are you doing?!
What are you doing?"
I'm just like, "Oh yeah,
I should probably care for my life."
I remember thinking that
and I'm just like, "Nah."
- [Connor] Either run or
help. You have two options.
- Should be all right.
Should be all right.
- So, yeah. Don't do what we did.
Connor did the correct thing and panicked.
- I could have helped,
but also I would've had
to run around the fire
and I was like,
"I don't know how dangerous this is."
My guess would've been, "How
about we leave it on the floor
and then all run."
- Yeah.
- So that happened.
I can't remember if anything else happened
during the campsite.
- I'm pretty sure these
gas cans have fail-safes
so that even if they somehow
light on fire like that,
they don't...
- That's why I was so calm.
- But also I know that you can't
heat up a metal gas canister for very long
before it goes boom.
- Yeah. That's true.
- I'm sure the campsite
would've loved that.
- Well, we were all right.
- We survived.
- I don't know how we survived.
- We didn't end up on r/WatchPeopleDie.
So don't worry. We're all good.
- All it took was a few
shakes and a bit of a blow.
It wasn't a big fire,
but it was just fire plus
gas canister, not good.
- Yeah. That could have ended very badly.
- Under any other circumstance,
I would've been in the same panic mode,
but kind of dunno why.
I was drunk, okay? I was very drunk.
- [Joey] Shockingly calm.
It was like, "Just put it out.
Just put it out."
- I remember the thought
going through my mind of,
"I should get up and run,
but the seat's so comfy right now
and it's really cold outside."
It was like your mom asking
you to get out of bed
when it's like 7:00 AM.
It is how people die.
- [Connor] Why people die in house fires.
- It is how people die. I was very stupid.
But at the time, it just felt
like the right thing to do,
in my mind. Which it wasn't. It wasn't.
I was very dumb.
- We could have died multiple times.
This is like a double
entendre, this title.
- Yeah, exactly.
- We almost died. We actually did.
- So then that happened
and then it got to around to 11 PM?
- [Garnt] 11 PM? I could
have still kept going.
- [Connor] Yeah, me too.
I wanted to keep going.
- But it gets to the point where,
my entire life I've been
conditioned to think
that no matter how cold it gets,
I can just drink more beer
and it will solve the problem.
This was the one time
when I was outside with a thick jacket on
and drinking more beer
didn't solve the problem.
Because I just kept getting colder.
I'm just like, "What's going on?"
So I start trying to drink more beer.
I just kept getting colder.
I'm just like, "What is this?"
- Well, the thing with alcohol
is that you don't actually get warmer,
but your body just thinks you're warmer.
- [Garnt] Yeah, you just
think you're getting warmer.
That's just a testament to how cold
it was actually getting
rather than how cold
my mind was thinking it was getting.
- At a point, I just wanted
to stop drinking the beer,
because I would pick it up,
and it would just
literally be freezing cold.
- It was not even nice to drink
'cause of how cold it was,
'cause outside was so cold.
- Would've been great in the summer.
- Oh, in the summer, I'd have loved it.
- It would've been amazing.
But when it's like zero degrees outside
and you're drinking zero-degree beer,
it's not that great.
- It was one of the few times
where you drink a beer and it gets colder
the longer you drink it.
(all laughing)
- It's fucking awful.
- The beers would, 'cause
they're in a crate,
the beers would start off
at a reasonable amount of coldness
and then they would get
to a reasonable coldness
to ice cold to almost frozen.
- Also, the thing about
ice cold beers that's nice
is that you're not normally drinking it
in ice-cold conditions.
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- So it warms up.
It's a nice temperature
and it's nice in your body.
"Oh, this is refreshing."
But when it's ice cold
in ice-cold conditions,
you're like, "This feels like a bad idea."
- It's torture.
- "This feels like a bad combination."
Perhaps lukewarm beer would've
been better, or hot beer.
That's why they drink hot wine
at the Christmas festivals.
- We did everything we
could to elongate this fire,
but nothing was working.
There was only so much we
could ration out this firewood.
I think the last log
lasted us for a full hour.
- There's only so many tiny little twigs
you find on the paddock right there
where it's like, "Yes, this will do."
- I remember there was a
tree next to where I pissed,
and I picked up the leaves.
I'm just like, "Okay, these
dead leaves, these'll work.
And they gave us like
a microsecond of heat
and that felt, to me at the
time, like a full 10 minutes.
We start using the beer packaging.
So we had all the cardboard packaging,
and we went from using the beer cardboard
to rationing it as a big burst of heat,
because that would give us
a nice big burst of heat
for a good five seconds.
We'd all crowd around, and we were like,
"All right, boys,
when do we do the next one?
When do we use the next one?"
- [Joey] I can't wait new longer.
- We eventually just didn't
even drink the beers.
But we'd still unwrap the beers
with all the packaging so
we could use it as fuel.
- Should have recycled,
but instead we needed heat.
- Yeah.
- Eventually, we ran
out of things to burn.
I know guys, I know.
- Ran outta resources.
- So I put Garnt in the fire.
Unfortunately, he didn't burn.
- So eventually, that was when we realized
we had to go to bed,
and so we packed everything up.
- At this point, it was
maybe around -1, -2.
It was starting to get
pretty fucking cold.
- It was starting to
get pretty, really cold.
Yeah.
It was negative degrees.
For you Americans, that's negative
from the freezing point of water.
So I dunno what the
freezing point of water
is in Fahrenheit, but it was below that.
- Below 32.
- Why is it 32?
- 'Cause 32 Fahrenheit
is zero degrees Celsius.
- Oh, okay.
- I didn't know that.
- I did not know that.
- That's 30-something. I'm pretty sure.
- Yeah.
- 33.8 is one degree Celsius.
- Yeah, 32 is zero. So it
was maybe 28 Fahrenheit.
- Yeah.
- This is when we came to realize how cold
it really was going to be,
without even like a piddly little fire
to heat us up.
I remember me and Connor
went into our tent first.
So me and Connor slept
with Nabi in his tent,
and Joey and Luke slept in another tent,
and everyone else slept in a third tent.
I remember Connor jumping in,
Connor jumping in and just realizing
how flimsy and thin his sleeping bag was.
- I literally had gotten a raincoat
that had just been fashioned into...
It didn't have any padding or anything.
I was like, "This is what I get
for ordering the only
available sleeping bag
on Amazon next-day delivery."
'Cause I remember it was like 20 bucks.
- 'Cause I remember,
I think the warmest coat you have, by far,
is your Drip jacket, and
this was the one time
in the past month I've seen
you without the Drip jacket.
It would've been very,
very useful, I imagine.
- The reason I didn't bring it
is because we were gonna
be burning a lot of shit.
I didn't want to get this nice jacket
that I paid way too much money for
super-smoky, and it's
probably gonna be messy, too.
It was messy. I dropped
condiments everywhere.
I was like, "I'm gonna just leave that."
- Yeah.
- Which I did.
- So Connor gets in this sleeping bag
and soon realizes that
this is not going to be
warm enough at all.
He just gets over and he's like,
"Garnt? Garnt, I give you
permission to cuddle me.
Garnt, we are cuddling tonight."
I'm like, "Connor, we
don't need to cuddle.
We don't need to cuddle."
Then I get into the tent and I realize,
"Fuck! We're gonna need to
cuddle tonight, Connor."
I take off my jackets,
as fast as possible,
then I try to get in the sleeping bag,
I zip myself up. I'm fucking freezing.
I saw like two caterpillars
next to each other,
like cuddling with each other.
Then that still isn't warm enough.
So I realized pretty soon
that I have to sleep with my jacket on,
because even with my jacket off,
it's not going to be warm enough.
Luckily at this point, I
think we were pretty drunk.
- I must say it was very
funny from the other tent,
when all I could hear was,
"Garnt, cuddle me, now!
Get closer to me."
- I was freezing!
- "I'll be the small spoon.
You be the large spoon.
Cuddle me now."
- Listen, I've seen enough
Bear Grylls to know what to do.
I knew what I needed to do.
- Drink my piss, now.
- Garnt, don't ask what I
fashioned my jeans into,
a piss filter.
I'm already drinking the
water. You can go next.
I've already pissed in it, Garnt.
- I think I was wearing
like maybe six layers.
I had fashioned my spare T-shirt
and put it around my
neck as a neck warmer,
'cause it was so cold.
- Okay. What was the
coldest part of your body?
What was the part that was hurting?
- [Both] My feet.
- It was the feet for me, too.
- I was wearing the FamilyMart socks;
that didn't help.
(Garnt laughing)
- The one time I was like,
"Dammit, FamilyMart!"
- I was rocking a pair of jeans.
It was fine. My legs were fine, honestly.
That wasn't the problem.
I was wearing a long-sleeve thin shirt
with a big thick jumper.
I went to bed using my coat as the pillow,
'cause I didn't have a pillow.
Woke up at like 2 AM, I
think, 'cause I was too cold.
I put the jacket on. It
didn't really help much,
'cause by that point,
I was already too cold.
- Like the jacket was ice cold.
- I feel like... 'Cause I was too cold.
I wasn't heating up at
all. So it didn't help.
But my feet were just too cold.
- The tactic that I had in my head was,
"Fall asleep before you really
start feeling the cold."
Before we went to the tent,
we just started downing
beers like nobody's business.
We're just like, "All right,
can we down a little bit?
Let's do it. We fucking need
it to sleep in this weather."
So after we downed the beers
and I start cuddling Connor, it worked.
I fell asleep actually pretty fast.
- Yeah. Me too.
I got a good amount of sleep, I think.
Not good quality sleep. I felt rough.
- I got like a good three,
four hours of sleep,
because I remember waking
up at around 4:00 AM
and that's when it
really started to hit me,
the fucking situation I was in.
- That was like the minimum.
- What time did you wake
up? Or did you sleep at all?
- I slept. I probably slept
maybe about two or three hours.
Then I woke up around
four-ish, the same thing.
Then I was just like, "I can't. I can't."
I checked the temperature.
It was like -6 Celsius,
and I was like, "Fuck it."
- I know that if you wake up
and you actually start looking
at your phone and stuff,
you will wake up.
So every time I woke up,
'cause I woke up sporadically
throughout the night,
I would just immediately force
myself to not do anything
and go back to sleep.
So I got to sleep until around
5:56, I think I remember.
- Yeah. I got out of the tent.
I was like, "I need to start walking."
- At that point, it was like
four or five degrees minus.
- I got out at like 4:00 AM,
with all the clothes I had on,
I was just like, "I'm
just gonna go for a walk,
'cause this is the only
way I can be warmer."
- I was so much colder walking.
- Really?
- Yeah. 'Cause I had the
problem of what happens
when you drink too many
beers. You need to pee.
- Right.
- So I really, really needed to pee,
and the toilet was very far away.
So I walked to it.
I bought a coffee from
a vending machine there
to heat my hands up, 'cause
I paid a dollar every time
I needed to heat my hands up.
I was so cold. I didn't even give a shit.
I didn't drink the coffee.
I just used it as a hand warmer.
So it was saving my life.
It was like my lifeline.
I had gone through four
of these $1 coffees
just to keep my hands warm.
'Cause I was like (shivering noises)
- Oh my God.
- It was awful.
It was dreadful.
I had to go pee, and peeing was painful.
But luckily, the one saving
grace of this campsite,
was at the toilet,
thank God, praise Japan,
had a bidet, and bidets have a heated...
- Heated toilet seat!
- So I sat on this toilet
seat for a good 15 minutes.
Just going (sighs blissfully),
just knowing that my ass
was being warmed gracefully.
It was amazing.
- One of my biggest fears
when it goes to camping,
is having to pee after
everyone's fallen asleep.
Because I have the smallest
bladder in the world.
- Getting out of the tent.
- Getting out of the tent
and waking everyone up
as you are going out the tent to pee,
which sometimes, if I'm drinking,
I need to pee two or three times.
- Next time, I'm just
bringing adult diapers.
(Joey laughs)
- Yeah. Luckily, they'll
warm you up, honestly.
- I'm bringing adult diapers next time.
- It would serve two things.
It would warm up my legs and
my lower half of my body,
and I wouldn't need to
worry about peeing anymore.
- Hold on, I gotta warm up.
- I actually remember,
even before we went to bed,
I remember telling these boys
about my irrational fears
when it comes to peeing when I'm camping.
Did you boys remember this?
- I remember stupid.
- Because we were talking
about horror movies before,
something to do with horror movies.
I can't remember; I was
pretty fucking drunk,
but anytime I pee in the wilderness,
like camping or whatever,
so you go up to a bush or something
and it's a bush that extends
as far as the eye can see.
Anything can be hiding in that bush.
I've seen enough horror movies to know
there could be a fucking monster
or Jason on the other side,
waiting to chop me up.
There could be anything.
So I have this irrational...
- I'm sorry. What are you, five years old?
- [Garnt] Yes, Joey. I'm five years old.
- Like Dexter's chilling in
the bush waiting for you?
- He could be. So ever since I was a kid,
every time I would go up to pee by myself,
I'd hear the boys just
bantering in the background.
I'd be about 20, 30
meters away, in the dark.
So they can't really see
me. But they know I'm there.
So I'm peeing in this bush,
I always have this irrational fear
that something is going
to come out of this bush
and attack me or grab me,
or a creature's gonna chomp
me up or something like that.
'Cause that's what happens
in every horror movie,
it's always the guy taking the piss
next to the lakeside or the bush
that he never expects
it. He's a bit drunk.
That's when they die.
That's when they always die.
- Right. You need to cut
down on the horror movies.
- I think Sydney's making you watch
one too many horror movies.
- So every time I go pee, I'm eagle-eyed,
looking for any movement.
Any shake of the bush,
I'm like ready to leg it the other way.
I don't even care if my
dick's out at this point,
I'm legging it.
- You should be thankful
that it was so cold,
because if it wasn't that cold,
I would've absolutely trolled you.
- Because it was cold, here I am,
here I am, keeping an
eagle-eye out of any sign
of a possible monster that
could come out of the bush.
But me being drunk, one of
you guys say something funny,
start laughing.
I look over, and I'm just like,
"The boys are just being boys."
I look back over and
I see someone's breath
going towards me.
- Like a white cloud.
- Like a white cloud. I'm like, "Fuck.
There's a monster hiding in that bush."
Then I soon realized,
literally half a second in,
that it's just my piss steaming.
(Joey laughs)
- [Garnt] So I gave myself,
my piss gave me a mini...
- You got scared from your pee.
- I did.
- Idiot.
- My piss gave me a
mini-fucking-heart attack,
because I thought there was
a monster hiding in the bush.
- Oh my God.
- Oh my God, that's the
funniest thing I've ever heard.
- That already shows how
cold it was even before,
even before we started sleeping.
So luckily, I'd held my
piss for as long as I could,
until I woke up.
I remember waking up and I was just...
- You can't get back in that
sleeping bag once you wake up.
- No, no.
- It's not possible.
- I gave up.
- No. So I remember waking up,
and I tried to go back to sleep.
Of course, this was the exact moment
that Connor and Nabi decided
to have a snoring contest.
- [Nabi] It wasn't us.
- Yes. Yes. You guys definitely did.
I don't know why they
chose this exact moment,
'cause I remember waking up.
- Why do you think I
got my own tent, dude?
- Like you can't hear.
You were like four feet
away from me, Joey.
- I remember waking up
and it was like dead silence.
I remember I had about a good
10 minutes of dead silence.
I remember checking my bladder,
to be like, "Do I need to pee?"
No, thank God. I don't need to pee.
Thank God. My bladder's empty enough
for me to be able to go back to sleep.
So I turn over, try and find
a nice comfortable position,
and then I just hear Connor
next to me going (snores).
Then I was just like,
"Connor, don't don't don't.
Don't you fucking dare."
Then he doesn't do anything more.
Then Nabi just goes (snores)
and then I'm just like,
"No, no, please no."
I get another five seconds of silence.
Connor turns over. (loud snore)
- And I'm just like, "For fuck's sake."
- I'm trying to get the blood
flowing as much as possible.
I'm breathing.
- I do remember that moment actually,
because that was around the time
where I decided to wake up
and all I could hear was
what sounded like two
really old motorboats
trying to start up.
(imitates motorboat)
- It was just like a feedback loop.
You just kept feeding into each other.
- I was like, "Are they going?"
- I don't normally snore,
but when I have to sleep on my back,
that's when I snore.
- Also, you guys were drinking, as well.
Naturally, you snore more when you drink.
- Well, that wasn't the only dilemma
I had to go through because now,
at this point, I had
sobered up a lot more,
at least a lot more that I
could definitely feel the cold.
So I realized that being in a tent,
you can warm up your body,
but the air in the tent is still cold.
It is still cold air.
So I was trying to
breathe through my nose,
and I swear to God, every breath I took
was like freezing the
moisture inside my nose.
- Are you saying you
became a mouth-breather?
- No. Yeah. Yeah.
So while these guys...
- [Joey] Stole my old
tactics, be a mouth breather.
- While these guys are
having a snoring contest,
I'm here trying to successfully
breathe through my nose
without it hurting.
After about five minutes, I'm just like,
"I gotta become a..."
- What is this, "Demon Slayer"?
- I have to master the
breathing technique.
I'm like, "I'm going to
become the thing I detested."
I became a mouth breather.
But even that didn't help.
I tried breathing through my mouth,
but it was still too fucking cold.
So I had to take my jacket off,
and try to fashion this kind
of pillow-scarf kind of thing,
where my face was being covered.
So that I had enough air.
- Cosplaying "Dune" or something?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah. Kind of.
So I tried to masquerade this mask on me
where I had enough air to breathe,
but it was also insulating the cold air.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- That didn't work, because then,
if anyone's tried to sleep
with the blanket over your head,
you soon realize that you
can't fucking breathe.
You can't breathe.
- It's very stuffy.
- Yeah. You're gonna get very stuffy.
You're probably gonna die
of carbon dioxide poisoning.
So basically, I had to make the choice
of trying to sleep suffocating
myself or freezing my lungs.
Neither choice sounded
like a good choice to me.
So here I am for 30 minutes.
I would put the cover over my head,
try to breathe through
it for a good 30 minutes.
Doesn't work, take it off.
Find another position.
- Sounds like you were one step away
from just breathing your
own farts for warmth.
- I mean, that might have
honestly been the best solution.
- Honestly, I would've taken
any solution that worked,
but eventually me trying to go to sleep,
Connor eventually wakes up
and he goes out the tent.
So I try sleeping
for another half an hour to 45 minutes
before I just give up
and just try going out.
At that point, everyone's already out.
I didn't know what these guys were doing.
I thought Connor had gone
for a walk or something.
I thought maybe they'd
gone back to another tent.
I had no idea what they were doing.
'Cause I remember them talking outside,
but when I went outside, nobody was there.
So, I remember trying to
find where everyone was
and then for some reason, I felt the car,
or I heard the car engine purring.
I was like, "Why is the car
on? What's going on here?"
Keep in mind, I had
contacts on before I slept.
So I had taken them off.
I couldn't see shit.
So I was trying to feel my way through.
Everything was blurry for me.
So I go towards the car,
and I see Connor just
sleeping on the driver's seat.
These motherfuckers had gone into the car.
- Big brain.
- [Garnt] Had gone into the car,
turned the engine on, and
just slept in the car.
Fuck the camping trip.
They had gone back to civilization.
- Listen, in my mind, I'm
like, "Listen, I've slept.
It's 6:00 AM. It's technically morning.
I've awoken. Now I want to get warm.
I'm going in the fucking car."
Because at that point I was like,
"What do we actually do?"
I don't know what to do.
I was like, "I can't sit
on the toilet for hours."
We're not gonna leave
for a few more hours.
I was like, "There's nowhere
I can go to get warm.
No one can accuse me of not camping.
I slept in the tent until 6:00 AM.
I'm now going in the car to heat up."
- I joined him, obviously,
to warm up a bit.
- Turned the engine on for a bit,
and then it got hot enough.
Then the sun was starting to come out,
so we just turned it off.
Then we're just chilling in the car.
I slept like four hours.
- I mean, I'm giving them shit,
but the only reason I'm giving them shit
was because I saw Connor
sleeping in the car.
I'm just like, "You fucking
genius. Big brain mode."
- I'm like, "Galaxy brain".
- I excitedly open the
car door, being like,
"You fucking geniuses."
Then I quickly see that
all the seats are taken.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- So originally, I was like,
"Come on, Joey, let's go in the car.
I'm gonna go in the car."
I didn't want all this wasted
electricity that I'm using,
'cause it is a massive
waste of electricity.
But at the time, I was
like, "I'm gonna die.
I'm gonna get in the
car. It's -4. Fuck this."
The other people were
taking photos of Fuji
and they were dying for their craft.
I salute them, but not me.
I had nothing to gain from that.
So I was like, "I'm going in
the car, Joey, come on in."
And then slowly, everyone
started trying to get in the car,
'cause they were also freezing.
- Then it basically turned into a sauna,
where people were coming in and out,
just trying to warm up.
- Yeah. Because I opened the car door,
and every fucking seat was
taken, and it wasn't filmed.
I'm glad it wasn't filmed,
'cause it would've quickly turned into
the saltiest moment of
Trash Taste this year,
'cause I was like, "Fuck these guys.
Fuck these guys. Fuck them."
I went for a walk trying to figure out
how I'm gonna warm myself up.
- It was great, 'cause the car
was slightly on a hill, as well.
So when reclined the chair,
it was literally like a flat bed.
The air blasting, 'cause it
doesn't really do anything
for the first 10 minutes,
'cause the car wasn't moving.
So it was like, "What are we doing?"
- So I'm still tired as fuck.
I start walking around.
I try taking some nice photos of Fuji,
but at this point, I'm fucking dying.
I couldn't give a shit.
- [Connor] I'm sorry.
You could have got in,
you know, could've squeezed in.
- There was literally no space.
- Could've got in the boot.
- Every space was taken.
- We could have stacked.
- I found my way, though.
I found a way to warm myself up.
So this was me using 100% of my brain.
'Cause I'm an engineer,
and what do engineers do?
We problem solve.
- I did that, too.
- Yeah, you did.
I can't blame you for not problem solving.
Unfortunately, I couldn't
go for the same solution,
because Nabi was fast asleep.
So I couldn't be like,
"Nabi, gimme the car keys."
- [Joey] "Get the fuck out."
- "Get the fuck out.
Let's go into the car."
- [Connor] "Give me the other car."
- So I walk over to take a piss,
to take a piss in the toilet,
and I see the vending machine.
Then like the fucking bulb
just lights above my head.
I'm just like, "Guys, I figured this out."
So I go back to my tent. I get my wallet.
I get my wallet and I just
start putting coins in.
I start buying coffee. 'Cause Connor...
- How many did you buy?
- I bought six in the end.
- Oh my God!
That sounds more inefficient
than using the car.
- Probably. It probably is.
But that was the only
solution I could come up with.
- Why did you not just
jump in the other car?
We had two cars.
- It's canned coffees by the way.
- So to explain, we had
a vending machine there,
and Japanese vending
machines have this option
where some of the drinks are warmed.
That was the only source
of heat I could find
in like a five-mile radius at this point.
So here I am, spending a
hundred yen for a coffee,
which to me are just
like heat packs, right?
I start packing them into my coat.
At this point, I actually
start rationing them.
So I start, so I take about six coffees,
rush back to the tent,
go back into my sleeping bag.
I throw two cans at my feet,
'cause my feet were the coldest.
The rest, I start packing
in my winter jackets.
I pack some in my bottom
pockets, some in my side,
my sleeve pockets, my side pockets;
have the best fucking
sleep of my life, man.
(Garnt laughs)
- It worked. It actually worked.
I got some proper air circulation
in this fucking sleeping bag, man.
- I felt so rough the next day.
I slept like 10 hours as
well. I just felt awful.
There's something about
eating just meat, as well,
that just makes me feel awful.
- Yeah. I get that.
- And a lot of beer.
- We didn't have the best
diet the night before.
- When I eat just meat, like only meat,
I feel like my body feels beaten up.
Like I need something else
to help stomach the blow.
- So yeah. Moral of the story is...
- Be more prepared.
- Don't underestimate the winter.
I thought it would be fine.
- Who gives a shit about
what Bear Grylls says,
when you could just get warm coffee?
That's the secret.
- Just get in the car.
Just get in the car.
- Why did Bear Grylls not go
to the nearest vending machine?
- All you need is a konbini.
Just go to a vending machine.
- Get a vending machine.
- Pack yourself some warm fucking coffee,
and just use that shit. Warm yourself up.
I don't know why Russians are complaining.
I've seen Siberian winters.
Just need a vending machine.
- Sometimes their car engines freeze.
Don't they leave the cars on sometimes,
'cause it freezes otherwise?
- Did you also watch that video
of the dude who went to Siberia?
- Was it really?
- It was that video that went viral.
It was on my recommended recently.
It's got like 30 million views
in six months or something,
of this dude who went
to Yakutsk in Siberia,
which is the coldest part of the world.
It's like -71 degrees or something.
- Colder that Antarctica?
- It's colder than Antarctica, yeah.
- Gotta fact check that, Ashley.
- Yeah. But it it's called Yakutsk.
Y A K U T S K.
Something like that.
- Where's the coldest place on Earth?
- But it's in Siberia,
and this dude does this
amazing mini-documentary
of him there and he's like,
"Yeah, so here I've got some
boiling water at 100 degrees,
and I'm gonna throw it out into the air
and it'll instantly freeze."
He just throws it.
- [Garnt] I've seen that, yeah.
- Instantly turns into snow,
because it's like -50 degrees.
It's like, "In normal circumstances,
if it's anywhere below zero degrees,
then school is canceled.
But here in Yakutsk, as
long as it doesn't hit -50,
kids are going to school."
I was like, "What the fuck?"
Yeah. It's insane.
- No, I remember seeing videos like that.
Let me see. Not just in Siberia,
but I think recently somewhere in America
had like a cold front where it was like...
- [Connor] Oh, Texas?
- Was it Texas?
- [Connor] Yeah. Texas had...
- Where I saw videos of
people doing the same thing,
where they would throw out the water.
Don't quote me on this,
'cause I'm not sure if it was Texas.
- It was Texas. It was Texas.
- Are you sure?
- The cold front? Yeah.
The cold was 'cause all
the electrical grid broke.
- This guy Discover with
Cenet, 32 million views,
six months ago, -71 degrees
Celsius, -96 Fahrenheit.
- Jesus Christ.
- [Nabi] It's not the coldest
habitable place on Earth,
but it's probably one of them.
- It's one of them. It's up there.
- [Nabi] It's one of the coldest cities.
- Yeah. Yeah.
'Cause I'm pretty sure
that Antarctica is like...
- Oh yeah. Center of the Arctic Circle
is probably colder, but
no one's living there.
- So I would see videos of people
throwing boiling water out,
and you'd see it freeze
and steam instantly.
But my favorite thing was people
who didn't realize that boiling water
is still boiling water,
and if you chuck it on yourself,
even if it's like -20
degrees weather outside,
there's still gonna be some boiling water.
You're still gonna burn yourself.
- Why were people
chucking it on themselves?
They were chucking it on themselves?
- They were chucking it in the air,
and the water, you know, fell down.
- Fell down.
- 'Cause how gravity works,
it would fall down on them.
- It's like, "Ah! Fuck!"
- "Let's just scald myself."
- The more you know. Boiling
water is still boiling.
Cold things are cold.
Camping in -4 degrees weather...
- I'm sure there's gonna be
some pro camping people watching this,
cringing to death hearing all the fails,
but that's camping, innit?
Fucking everything up.
- It was still fun.
- It's part of the fun.
- It's still fun.
- I'm sure there's gonna be
some people watching be like,
"What? -6, -5, that's not cold."
- Basic. Basic.
- But that's how it always is in these.
They'll be like, "Oh, you
woke up at 4:00 AM, bro.
I wake up at 1:00 AM every day
and I inject meth into my eyes.
You don't know what waking up early is."
- Weak morning routine.
- It's like, "Shut the fuck up.
Let people complain about
what is relative to them
for a moment, please."
- Look, all I'm saying
is Yuru Camp lied to me.
They went camping in the winter,
and they didn't need to
go into the fucking car
to warm themselves up.
They were comfy in their little coats.
- I wanna see that Yuru Camp episode.
- Where's the Yuru Camp episode
where they become mouth breathers?
If they don't become mouth breathers,
then I don't think it's
accurate, honestly.
- Do they have clearly defined nose?
That could be mouth breathers.
- No, they don't.
- They might be mouth breathers, Garnt.
- They probably are mouth breathers.
- They're pretty mouth breathers.
- This episode is sponsored by Harry's.
Harry's is an award-winning razor brand
that makes a full range
of grooming essentials.
They were founded on the belief
that you shouldn't have to choose
between an incredible
shave and a fair price.
- You guys know already, I use Harry's.
I pretty much only shave with Harry's.
I know that sounds like
an ad, but it's real.
When I went back to the UK,
they actually sold Harry's in the UK,
and I put like five boxes
of the 12-pack razors
in my suitcase.
Genuinely, it's the cleanest shave.
I'm telling you, these razors are clean,
very good, and they last a while.
- What a perfect time,
'cause it's that time of the year again,
time for a fresh start
and new resolutions.
- Whether you're trying
to manage your finances better
or just trying to look your best
going into the new year,
Harry's can help with that.
- To start the new year with some savings,
new customers can redeem
a Harry's trial set
for just three smackaroos.
Harry's delivers a
close, comfortable shave
at a fair price, as low as $2 per blade.
- And guys, Harry's is
giving their best offer
to our listeners.
New Harry's customers
can redeem a starter set.
You get a five-blade
razor, a weighted handle,
foaming shave gel, and a travel cover
to protect your blades
when you're on the go.
That's $13 value for just $3.
There's truly never been a
better time to try Harry's.
Go to Harrys.com/trashtaste
to try Harry's today.
Back to the episode.
- Do you guys have any irrational fears?
'Cause I don't know if I'm the only one...
- How irrational?
- [Garnt] I dunno.
I don't know. What is
your biggest fear, Joey?
What is your biggest fear?
- My biggest fear?
- What is your biggest irrational fear?
- Not having a great beard. I'm kidding.
Actually go, sorry. Sorry
to bring up the camping.
We'll go back to the irrational fears.
We'll go back to that.
The beard definitely helped staying warm.
I gotta admit, now that
I've let it grow out.
My face was never cold.
- But didn't your snot freeze?
- [Connor] Yeah. So here,
'cause I had a cold,
'cause it was so cold.
My snot, obviously it must have dribbled
while I was sleeping.
It froze on the arch of
my, underneath my nose.
- Ow.
- It was awful 'cause I
was like, "What is this?"
and flicked it and just
peeled off all my skin.
And I was like, "Ow. Ow."
But yeah, the beard otherwise is great.
- Yeah.
- But I think this is the
longest I'll let it go.
It's getting pretty long.
- Does it get any longer than that?
- It can do.
- Oh really?
- I think it'll keep
going longer and longer.
- Oh, damn.
I kind of wanna see you
with like the longer...
- Part of me wants to
try it, but I'm like,
"Maybe I should just save
that for when I'm bald."
(Joey laughs)
- No, you gotta test it out
now, before you go bald.
- Yeah. That's what I was thinking.
- See if it works.
- But I'm not gonna
lie, I don't know if...
There's probably a lot of
bearded people watching this.
It kind of is getting
somewhat itchier than usual.
- Yeah. I feel that.
- Do you get this? Do you
get this, bearded people?
- No, I get that.
- There are probably no solutions
that are like, "How you
maintain a beard perfectly."
Which I don't.
- One time, I grew it out
to as long as I could,
and I don't think it'll
ever get as long as yours,
but I remember one time it...
- I'm at the baby stages.
It's still growing.
- Yeah, but that length that you have,
is probably the longest it can go for me.
- Oh really?
- Yeah. Because my Asian side forbids it.
- I will say that doing
this feels really nice.
Just be like, "Yeah."
- Have you gotten to the point, though,
where you're kind of turning in your bed
and your beard brushes
up against the pillow
and it starts to get a bit itchy?
- Sometimes, yeah.
The worst thing is, 'cause
we have to wear masks,
when it's getting thicker...
- With a mask is the worst.
- Masks suck.
It's like I'm breathing
into my own beard jungle.
I can feel it.
- It's ticklish, as well.
- Yeah. It's like wet. It's awful.
- How long are you gonna grow it?
- I'm probably gonna shave it tonight.
Not all off. I'm just gonna cut it, sorry.
I'll trim it down, 'cause
got a video shoot tomorrow.
I'm gonna be sad to stop letting it grow,
but maybe I'll try it again.
- You should try it. You should try it.
- I'll do it again sometime.
- How come you wanted to
grow it out a bit longer?
- I just wanted to see if
it looked better thicker.
I think it does look a
little better thicker
than normal.
- It definitely adds on
the age, that's for sure.
- I look older. I look more angry.
- Who doesn't look older
with a beard, though,
is what I'm saying.
- I could probably look
my age if I grew a beard.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Probably.
- I could see Garnt in
10 years with a goatee.
I don't know why.
- I wanna see that.
- Garnt with a goatee. I could see it.
- I don't think I've ever seen you with,
have you ever grown out your beard
to see where the absolute limit is
before it stops growing?
- No, because I don't like
how I look with a beard
a lot of the times.
There's this...
- [Connor] I want goatee Garnt.
- There's this perfect sweet spot,
and then it just kind of looks like pubes.
(Joey laughs)
- It goes from nine o'clock shadow to,
"Wow, you really should
trim that bush, mate."
So I always trim it when
it gets to that point.
So I don't know if I'm ever
gonna grow out the beard,
because Sydney's like,
"Yeah, it's a good idea.
It's a good idea."
Then I reached the pube stage.
She's like, "Maybe you should trim it."
- It's in-between phases that look bad.
- After the pube phase is
when it starts to look good.
- Commit, Garnt.
- Maybe I will, one day.
- Goatee Garnt.
- Everyone has the pube stage.
You have to go beyond the pube stage.
- He wears turtlenecks.
He's literally made for goatees.
- Exactly.
- Goatee Garnt. Do it.
- Maybe, maybe one day.
- Do it.
- Maybe when I reach my midlife crisis.
You know how like...
- You'll be the first one there.
- I could do a goatee.
I could just shave it all off and be like,
"Hello, fellow goatee wearers."
- I did a goatee once when I was shaving,
and immediately, I was like,
"Oh God, I look like I touch children."
(Garnt laughing)
- Fuck, Joey.
- It was actually like I immediately,
I was immediately like,
"Nope, I'm not having this
on my face any longer."
- Calling out anyone with a goatee.
- As opposed to like Shinobu.
- It just doesn't work for me.
I realize I have one of those faces
that's just like it's
either beard or nothing.
Like goatee, mustache...
- Well, you're not helping yourself out.
- I tried the bootstrap beard
and stuff like that, with
the really thin beard.
- Oh, I don't like those.
- That doesn't work for me.
Mustache doesn't work for me.
Goatee doesn't work for me.
It's either this or nothing.
I just have one of
those faces, I realized.
You just have to try it out.
- I wish mustaches were more "in".
I like mustaches.
- I wish I could rock a mustache.
- Mustaches look kinda sick.
- I wish I had the face for a mustache.
They do look sick.
- It just looks like you're
about to invent something.
(Joey laughs)
- You look like you're
about to pioneer somewhere.
- Depends on what kind of
mustache you have, right?
- You could work a mustache.
- I don't get, you know
that thing that people have
where you don't grow that
much hair in the middle?
You need it to grow more there.
- I don't think you would suit a mustache.
- [Connor] No, I don't think so either.
- You don't think so?
I also think you'd look like
you touched short people
if you wore a mustache.
- Garnt! You're giving
people with a mustache
a bad rep here, boys.
- No, no, no, no, no.
- Some people can rock it so hard,
and I'm so jealous of
people who can do that.
- If he had a mustache
and those massive glasses,
you know what I mean?
Those massive glasses,
you would definitely...
- You're calling out some of our viewers.
They're probably gone.
- No, but I'm sure they
don't look that bad.
- Saying it's just my face.
My face just looks hideous.
- For some people, it just works,
and there's no explanation for it.
- Here's a still image,
Mudan. Put a mustache on.
- I've seen dudes with just mustaches,
just goatees, just bootstraps,
where it's like, "Fuck.
You kill that shit."
- [Garnt] Put some glasses on him as well.
Put some big glasses.
- Put some glasses and then you'll see
it just doesn't work for some people.
- I don't know. Maybe it works.
Maybe it's just my imagination.
- Amazing. Bet it looks amazing.
- If it looks amazing, you have to do it.
- I think I'd look like a '90s porn star.
- Is that a good thing or a bad thing?
- It's a great thing.
The 2000s porn stars, the Johnny Sins era.
So yeah, '90s is
mustaches, all that stuff.
- That's like '70s.
- '90s.
- '70s porn stars had
the thick thick mustache.
- That was a look. That was
a look. Bring it back, Garnt.
- Maybe I will. Who knows?
- I can't imagine you with a mustache.
- Garnt would look like
a detective if he did it.
I wanna see Garnt with a fucking mustache.
- Oh, I dunno.
How long does it take for
you guys to grow out a beard?
How much commitment does it take?
- I dunno how long this has taken.
This is taking a while.
- My max, I think, is a
month and a half, two months.
Then it hits a point where it
just won't grow any longer.
- That's a long time.
- It takes a long time to grow a beard.
- It takes a long time.
- Months that I don't have,
and it looks scruffy in the middle parts.
When it's a full beard and
I can trim it properly,
yeah, it'll look good.
- When I reach my midlife crisis,
that's when I'll grow a beard.
- You're saying I reached
my midlife crisis?
- [Garnt] Sorry?
- Have I reached my midlife crisis?
- I mean, maybe you have, Connor.
- I haven't got my
health check results yet.
Maybe I have.
- So you might be at midlife.
- It could be three-quarters.
- I feel like growing a beard
or doing something crazy
with your facial hair
is the male equivalent of
when girls want a big change in their life
and they just cut their
hair off or something,
it's like the male equivalent.
- Like I broke up, I cut my hair.
- We need...
- I broke up. I grow a beard.
- We need to change the stigma.
The stigma around it.
- If you grow a beard at
any point in your life,
you're a sumo. You deserve it.
Go. You go, bro. Get a beard.
- What if you can't grow a beard, though?
- Sucks to be you, bro.
- Some people just can't.
- Stigma.
- That doesn't mean you're
having a midlife crisis
if you grow a beard, Garnt.
Fuck you.
You can grow facial hair
if you want to, king.
Go ahead.
- I grew my beard out in my early 20s.
- Yeah. Midlife crisis.
- Midlife crisis, shit.
- In YouTuber years,
that is a midlife crisis.
- True. That is true.
- Utterly.
- But anyway, going back
to irrational fears.
So I remember...
- Have we said our fears
on a podcast before,
like our main fears?
- No, no.
We did an episode where we
talked about our fears, right?
- Actually, it was a clickbait, though.
- No we talked about...
- What was I scared of?
- Huh?
- Tight spaces. Or I
remember we talked about
crawling into tight spaces.
- Yeah, yeah. 'Cause you were
talking about the cave story.
- Yeah, yeah.
'Cause I remember, I just realized this,
as I was taking another piss,
where most of my
irrational fears come from,
and it is from horror movies.
Specifically from horror movies
that I would watch as a kid.
I think that's why I detest horror movies,
'cause I remember
most of the horror movies
I've watched in my life
are between the age of
five to 10 years old.
The reason for this is
every time I'd go to my cousin's house,
he'd put on a horror movie.
How it'd start is I'd go
around to my cousin's house
and be like, "Oh, can we
watch "Dragon Ball Z"?
Can we watch "Dragon Ball Z"?"
So they'd put on "Dragon Ball Z"
and I'd be into it,
then all the parents would go
off and do their own thing.
They would ask the older cousins
to take care of the kids.
As soon as the adults left,
they were like, "Yo, you
wanna see a horror movie?
You wanna see someone get butchered?"
I'm like, "No, that scares
me. It gives me nightmares."
- How old are you?
- Huh?
- Between like five and 10 years old.
- Fuckin' hell. A little too young.
- So I remember, I think I
was seven or something...
So I'm gonna say the irrational fear.
Every time I approach my car
and it's just in a car park,
could be empty, could be full.
But I'm by myself and it's dark.
First thing I have to
do, check the backseat.
Make sure no one's in it.
(Connor laughs)
- Second thing I have to do,
I have to go under
and check that there's nobody
hiding underneath my car.
- [Connor] Do you check that every time?
- Like 90% of the time.
- [Joey] Really?
- I do it because I don't
feel safe unless I do it.
- What's gonna be under your car?
- [Garnt] Here's the reason.
- A monster.
- Here's the reason why.
So when I was about, I can't remember,
between five and seven.
I think I was seven years old.
I go to my cousin's house,
and of course, it's like,
"Garnt, it's horror movie time again."
I'm like, "No, please no."
We're putting in the horror movie.
This time, it's "Urban Legends".
- Is it good?
- I dunno if it's good.
Scared the shit out of me as
a kid, I'll tell you that.
- Oh yeah, I bet.
- I've never watched it since.
- You might get PTSD if you watch it now.
- [Garnt] Honestly.
- You will overcome your fear.
- Well maybe, maybe.
It's a slasher horror movie.
So it was like '90s.
So that's when slasher
horror movies were in.
- [Connor] Like the "Scream" era.
- Yeah. The "Scream" era.
That's the horror movie
era that I grew up with
and that's the kind of horror
movies that traumatized me.
I remember
it was this guy.
I can't remember the exact
things that happened,
but I remember it was surprise, surprise,
about urban legends.
You'd have these urban
legends that were spread out
and sometimes these urban
legends would come true.
I can't remember what the
exact urban legends were,
but I remember this one scene.
It was a guy who was
basically dressed up as Death
and he had a scythe.
I think part of the urban legend was
that there would be this
guy in the back of your car
while you're driving.
This actually happened in the movie.
There was this person driving the car
and how he died was
someone emerged from the back
with a scythe and just
chopped him up to death.
Of course, as a kid, that terrified me,
'cause I remember thinking,
"If I ever grow up and
get my driver's license,
at any point in the dark,
someone could come up from the back seat
and stab me in the neck
or slice my neck open."
- I kind of get that.
- So that is just ingrained into my mind.
But the second death in that movie,
or it might be the third or the fourth,
I can't remember.
So this rumor gets spread around, right?
That there's a guy in the backseat,
there's a serial killer,
and this is how this person died.
So, of course, the fourth guy,
he thinks he's better than this.
He goes towards his car.
He's a bit scared, but what does he do?
He checks the backseat.
Of course, he's like...
- I've beat the system.
- Ha. I beat the system. It's so dumb.
Out of nowhere, the guy is
hiding underneath the car
and slices his ankles.
He starts crawling away.
I remember this scene to this day.
That's why, if I ever approach a car,
I'm beating the system.
First thing I'm doing,
I'm checking underneath the car.
Second thing I'm doing,
I'm checking the backseat, right?
There's no...
- Then what if Death's like,
"Big plot twist, passenger seat."
- Look, look, look. If there's a sequel,
if there's "Urban Legends 2",
where someone adds on to this system,
I'm fucked.
- [Connor] Why?
- But until then, I'm checking
underneath every car I go to,
and every backseat, if I'm by myself,
'cause I'm not getting my ankles sliced.
I'll tell you that much.
- How did this man, not to nitpick,
but how did he use a scythe in a car?
- [Garnt] I don't know.
- Was this like an SUV?
- Mini-scythe.
- This must have been a big scythe, man.
You can't swing it in a car.
The scythes are not short tools.
Maybe a sickle, a sickle
might have worked.
- I like how that's your
first question and not,
"How did he get into the car?"
- The first thing I was
thinking when he said this,
I'm like, "How did this man
swing a scythe in a car?"
I can barely swing my arms in a car.
- That's a good question.
I should have asked that as a kid.
- Maybe if he kind of put it forward
and then brought it backwards.
But then how would you
slice it underneath?
I feel like
there's a lot of ways this could go wrong.
- You're being a little
too realistic here.
We first have to question,
"Why is Death in my car?"
- That's why I'm like,
I was gonna be scared
until the many plot holes
that were available.
I suddenly feel a lot safer.
- Irrational.
- I feel like, "This is good."
- I feel like, as an adult,
you can pick apart the plot holes
in a lot of horror movies,
and they stop being scary.
- [Connor] That's true.
- As a kid, you're like,
"(screaming) He's bleeding!
He's bleeding! What the fuck?"
- I get that backseat bullshit,
because there's a lot of
Japanese horror films, as well,
where that's very cliche.
The other one that scares me is,
and I hated this because my new place
that I currently have has this,
but in the bathroom,
your mirror has a medicine cabinet.
(Garnt laughing)
- It's the thing of you're
brushing your teeth,
and the medicine cabinet's slightly open,
and then you close the medicine cabinet
and then the monster
is standing behind you.
Every now and then, I
have that thing where
if I'm in the dark and the
medicine cabinet is open,
before I close it, I just look behind me.
- Do you actually?
- Do you take a single
breath before you close?
You're just like, "Okay."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm kind of like, I see it open.
I'm like, (breathes out
forcefully) "Okay, I'm good.
Okay guys, I'm good. Let's go."
I get that every now and then.
- I don't have any rituals like that
to stop me from being scared
of something like that.
- I don't know.
I think to this day,
there's some part about
me where it's like,
"I'm still scared of the dark."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- For whatever bullshit reason.
It's not because it's like,
"I'm afraid of the guy behind me
as I'm at the medicine
cabinet," or whatever,
but it's like, in the back of your head,
in the back of your fucked-up
imagination somewhere,
you're like, "This is a possibility."
- It's like when you're sleeping,
and you're like, "Did
I leave my door open?"
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You know you didn't,
but now you're gonna go check.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you're like, "I thought I did,
but I definitely didn't,
but I have to check."
- Right, right, right, right.
- It's kind of like that.
Where you make yourself
think something is there.
So now you have to check.
- Exactly.
- Otherwise you can't
stop thinking about it.
I think I've had stuff like that with,
"There could just be a monster
on the other side of the
bed if I turn around.
But I won't know unless I turn around.
Guess I won't turn around."
I have had thoughts like that.
But I never actually like...
- Put it into practice.
- Even when I think, "Oh, I could just die
if there was a guy standing
in my hallway with a knife."
I don't actually think
that he's gonna be there,
but I check.
- You check just in case.
- But I know there's no way
in hell someone's there.
- Yeah.
- But you just have to confirm it.
I also get that every now and again,
where it's the most irrational thoughts,
where sometimes there's,
you close the door and you're like,
"Maybe there's a guy on the other side.
Maybe there's someone
in my house right now."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I don't know.
Especially in the nighttime,
and you hear something in
the middle of the night,
in your living room or something.
You're like, "I know
there's nothing in my house,
(Joey laughs)
- But what if?
- What was that?
- What if? I'm like,
"I'm pretty sure there's
no ghosts in my house."
I'm confident in my belief of ghosts
that this place isn't haunted or whatever,
even if there might be
some haunted places in the world,
but I'm pretty sure this
place isn't haunted,
but then what the fuck was that noise?
It could be the wind.
Definitely not the wind.
No, definitely the wind.
Definitely not the wind. Could be.
You start second-guessing yourself.
- Exactly. I feel that,
especially recently with
some horror games I played,
I feel that just resurfaced.
It's not until you recently
consume content like that
that you start to realize,
"Oh, yeah. I think I'm
still afraid of this shit."
I remember after I played
"P.T." for the first time,
that made me so...
I was like, "Hallways, lights on.
Everywhere I go. I'm not
turning this shit off.
Fuck that."
(Garnt laughing)
- It's so irrational.
It's like, "Of course she's
not gonna be standing there
at the end of the hallway."
- Do you ever get the irrational fear
that someone who's close
to you is not okay,
and then you just text
them, like, "Are you okay?"
(Joey laughing)
- I get that. I get that.
- You're like, "I had this weird dream.
Just checking in that you're all right."
- It's like, "You haven't
texted me in a while.
We good? You good?"
(Connor laughs)
- Sometimes I'm just like,
sometimes you go to a night out
or hang out with someone,
and you're just like,
"They said 10 words less
than what they usually said.
Maybe there's something going on."
- "They were blinking
a lot more than usual."
- They were signaling something.
- Morse code, maybe?
(Joey laughs)
- Oh my God.
- I think part of the reason
why I have so many lights on in my house
is because of irrational fears like this.
My mom would bollock me as a kid,
'cause every time my mom
and dad would go out,
they'd come home to a
house full of lights.
They were like, "Garnt,
stop wasting electricity!"
For the longest time,
I think they just thought I would forget
to turn off the lights.
I never just told them, "No,
I'm just actually scared.
But what if there's darkness?
And what if there's something
hiding in that darkness, Mom?
You don't know. I'm in
this house by myself."
- In "Squid Game", they died in the dark.
- Exactly.
- You never know.
What if "Squid Game"
just happens in your room
while you're sleeping?
You have to start defending yourself.
(Garnt laughing)
- Try "Squid Game".
- So Trash Tastes camping.
It's when the lights went off.
- When the fire went out.
Everyone was like...
- Get to the corner!
- Closest weapon.
- I did come to the realization,
not the realization,
but the appreciation of lights.
(Joey laughing)
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- Especially camping. Especially camping.
You really do appreciate lights and fire.
- The appreciation of light.
- Oh my God.
- Jesus Christ.
- You know, heat is pretty good.
Being warm is a vital part of life.
- Light's pretty underrated.
- [Garnt] Just some things you just...
- You know, clothes is
actually pretty useful.
(Joey laughs)
- [Garnt] Honestly, they're pretty hot.
- Yeah, no shit they are, Garnt.
- I'm just saying,
I've never appreciated a hot shower more
than after we came back
from that camping trip.
- [Connor and Joey] True.
- I could just turn on the hot water
and immediately just warm myself up.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I'm just like, "Damn, man.
This shower is hitting different.
It is hitting different, man."
- That was the best shower
and sleep I had, though,
when we came back. It was so good.
- Yeah.
- I actually think that
fixed my sleeping schedule,
'cause I've been getting
up at a reasonable time.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Dude, I knocked out at like
9:00 PM. I was so done.
(Connor laughs)
- I was like, "I'm not
staying up. Fuck that."
- Anything else you guys
wanna bring up or anything?
- Nope. Just wanna let you
know that, no clickbait.
In this episode, we did
actually almost die twice.
Three times, if you include
the surprise attack from the bush.
- Garnt was this close to death
from a surprise Jason.
- Almost died from getting
scared by his own piss stream.
- I'm just saying, I love you, cuz,
but fuck you at the same time
for literally giving me...
- You have an asshole cousin.
(Garnt laughs)
- That's so cruel.
- I love my cousin.
- Was he a teenager?
- Huh?
- He's seven years older
than me. So he's...
- Oh, yeah, a teenager.
That's the asshole part.
- He's the closest thing I
have to an older brother,
and thinking back, that's a
very older brother thing to do.
- That is a very older
brother thing to do.
- I love you, cuz.
You are like an older brother to me,
but also fuck you for showing me
all those horror movies as a kid.
- Oh, it's so terrifying.
- I remember one thing,
for some reason that sticks out my mind,
my older brother teaching me was like,
"You know what socks are for, right?"
I was like, "No, what are socks for?"
He's like, "To clean up the messes
that you spill on the floor."
And I'm like, "Oh, what?
That makes a lot of sense."
Like when you're holding a cup of tea
and you spill it on the floor.
- You just step on it?
- Step on it. Just use your sock.
I was like...
- I dunno if that's the dumbest thing ever
or if it's an actual life-hack.
- And I was like, "You know
what? That's kind of big brain."
- It's kind of big brain.
- If it's not a big spill.
Obviously, if it's big, don't
just start putting your...
- That's an awful piece of advice.
- No, it's not. It's a
little bit. Little spill.
- If you have some thick socks, too.
- There is nothing worse than wet socks.
- Well, for like a brief
moment. Your body heat...
- How much water are we talking about?
- A tiny bit of spillage, like
a cup of tea or something.
- Then you rub it on the carpet
to warm it up and dry it off.
- If it's a spill that
you can actually feel
on your foot, on the sole of your foot.
- I do, for a brief moment.
I still do it to this day.
- But hey, the floor's clean.
- It's like kicking ice under the fridge.
- What do you mean?
- When you spill ice, you
kick it under the fridge.
The ice thing.
- I mean, I don't do it
anymore, but I used to.
- You don't you put it in the sink?
- If you drop the ice
while you're popping it.
- Well, it depends on
how much ice comes out.
- You know, two or three cubes.
Just kind of.
- Get it under there.
- Just kick it under.
- Just damage the floor, you know?
- Did your brother teach you that as well?
- No, I did that myself.
(all laughing)
- That's what you're gonna teach your kid
when you get home.
- I hope my kid never watches Trash Taste.
- "Son, five-minute
life-hack, kick the ice."
- This is a Trash Taste life-hack.
- This is reverse
life-hacks, you shouldn't do.
(Garnt laughs)
- You think I'm gonna ruin
FamilyMart socks like that?
- Exactly.
- You're gonna put them in the wash after.
- No, no, no.
- That's 'cause you have white.
I only have black socks.
- I mean, that's your
life-hack right there.
- Yeah, just buy black socks. Don't think.
- Does that mean you don't
own FamilyMart socks?
- No, I don't.
(Joey tsks)
- I'm fine with not doing that.
I'm happy with my socks.
I like having black socks.
I don't have to think.
- If FamilyMart brought
out a black sock variant.
- Then I might.
- FamilyMart, I hope you're listening.
- I mean, you do need some black socks.
Joey? Joey?
Looking at you, Joey.
- What? I have black socks.
- I know. You just never wear them.
- I never wear them.
(Garnt laughs)
- I swear to God, every
picture that's been taken
within the past month, I see
FamilyMart socks poking out,
no matter the outfit.
- I deadass have about nine
pairs of FamilyMart socks,
and I just cycle through it every week.
- Their poor supplier of
socks is working overtime.
- Dude. They're amazing.
- Poor factory workers.
- Please bring out a black pair.
- Working overtime to have to
sustain Joey's sock demand.
- Just going back to a random thing,
I gotta ask you.
So you hear something in
the living room, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Maybe you're half asleep.
How does Aki handle that?
- She's like, "Go to the living room."
- She asked you to check it?
- She's like, "Sweetie,
can you go check it?"
I'm like, "Woman, what the fuck?
Why am I the one to go?
You're the one that's curious. You go."
- Yeah. I hate it.
Because I'm not scared
until they ask me to check,
and I feel like their fear
gets transferred over to me.
(Connor laughs)
- Before that I was just like,
"Oh, I guess something knocked
over in the living room."
- Just a piece of wind.
Then I hear, "Garnt!
Garnt, I hear something.
I hear something in the living room.
Garnt, go check it. Garnt."
I'm like, "Sydney, it's probably nothing."
"Garnt, I need you to go check it now."
I'm like, "Fuck me."
Now that I'm going to
check, now I'm like...
- Then "Resident Evil" music
starts playing in my head.
(Garnt laughs)
- I was like, "Oh my God,
there's a zombie in the living room."
- Then I have to,
if I'm going to check the living room,
even if I know it's nothing,
I have to find a possible
weapon, just in case.
- [Connor] Oh my God.
- Just in case. Just in case, you know?
I have to find something that I can smack
a possible animal or person with.
Just in case.
- Just in case.
- An animal?
- You don't know what it could be.
- Smack a ghost.
- If it's an animal, I'm near certain
you would hear a lot more noise.
It would probably be breaking everything.
- Maybe they're sneaky. I don't know.
- That's how I discovered
the cockroach from last week.
- Do your houses have chimneys?
You ever slept in a house with a chimney?
- No.
- They make a lot of noise.
- Do they?
- Yeah. Unsettling noises.
- Howling.
- I had,
I did live in house with
the chimney as a kid,
and it was blocked up,
but it still made like the
(imitates wind howling).
- When it's open, the
noises that those make
are fucking terrifying.
Like a wolf howling all the time.
(Joey howls)
- It's literally the
stereotypical ghost noise.
(Joey laughs)
- It could be pretty scary sometimes.
- What if it's not the wind?
What if it's just a bunch of ghosts?
- It could be.
- "Let me in."
"It's cold."
- It's from all the
ghosts from all the Garnts
that got killed in bushes.
- Yeah.
(Connor makes shivering ghost noise)
- I need the statistics of how many people
have been killed while
pissing next to a bush.
I just need to put my mind at ease.
- I'm gonna bet that most of the deaths
are from electric fences
and them peeing on them
or something.
- Yeah. Probably something like that,
or an animal coming out or something,
like a bear coming out.
- Animals comes through.
"What do you want?"
- Exactly. That's what
I'm worried about, Joey.
I'm worried about an animal
coming out or something.
- You'll hear it. You'll hear it.
- You'll hear it.
- If it's big enough to kill you,
you will hear it.
- [Garnt] No, no, no, no.
- It's not gonna be like, "Mah."
- Okay, but how do I distinguish
between an animal ruffling the bushes
and just the wind?
- The wind is very different.
- It's very different.
- The wind is constant,
but an animal is like
(loud skittering sound).
- You will see it violently moving.
- Yeah.
- You'll see it.
Even though you are there,
you'll see it on the top.
- I don't know, man.
"Jurassic Park" has taught me different.
- "Jurassic Park" ain't shit, Garnt.
It's a great movie,
but it's not giving you survival tips.
- I don't go out into the bush and think,
"Oh, shit. What if a
Velociraptor comes out?"
- You think you'll find Jason in Hokkaido?
- Could be. I'm used to England, man.
We have nothing to be
scared of in England.
Whenever I'm in another country...
- Japanese policeman,
randomly stopping you in
the middle of a field,
asking you to be checked, as opposed to...
- I have an irrational
fear of Japanese policeman
coming out of the bush.
"Oh, you can't be here."
- You have more chance
of a Japanese policeman
stopping you from peeing in a bush
than you do from an animal
or something killing you.
- I'd rather get arrested
than violently murdered by an animal, man.
That's all I'm saying.
- You don't want to be
caught with your dick down
and a flashlight shining on you.
That is not what you want.
(Garnt laughs)
- That is true.
That's been our irrational
fears on Trash Taste today.
- You know who hasn't died
from peeing in the bush?
Our patrons.
- Or they have been. We don't know.
- Look at all these people.
Look at all these people
that haven't almost died.
Maybe you have, I don't know.
I don't know. Maybe something.
Maybe you've escaped death.
- The backseat of the car.
- Tell us your near-death experiences
in the comments down below.
- Also, tell us your irrational fears.
Do you check the backseat
of the car before going in?
Do you check underneath the car?
- [Joey] Garnt's trying to find some way.
- Please. Please, I can't be the only one.
I can't be the only one
who has a weird ritual in my life
just because of some movie I saw as a kid
that I can't forget.
- Looking for the 17 Reddit post for that.
Hey, if you'd like to support the show,
then make sure to go to
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Follow us on Twitter, send us
your memes on the subreddit,
and if you're heading out,
listen to us on Spotify.
- And get some Trash Taste merch.
- Hell, yeah! Get the Trash Taste merch!
- [Garnt] Look at this.
Look at that. Look at that.
- We have T-shirts. We have hoodies.
- It gonna be available when this...
- Yeah, yeah.
- Comes out.
- Yeah. For pre-order.
- So go and grab something.
- Grab some right now.
- Link's in the description, check it out.
- Bye, gamers.
- Bye.